Es wird zu einer beliebten Tradition im Rasenfunk vor der eigentlichen Episode ein Vorwort zu sprechen. Im aktuellen Fall aus folgendem Anlass. Ihr hört nun eine Folge zu Fußballpodcasts und naturgemäß fallen sehr sehr viele Podcastempfehlungen. Deshalb rate ich euch, geht noch bevor ihr weiterhört unbedingt jetzt gleich auf rasenfunk.de slash tribünengespräch und in den show notes zu dieser episode findet ihr zuallererst verlinkt ein pdf das druckte euch aus ganz oldschool auf papier ziemlich funky so wie man das früher gemacht hat in den 90ern und dann könnt ihr mitschreiben euch die podcasts notieren die euch interessant erscheinen die ihr vielleicht mal hören wollt es werden viele interessante podcasts genannt ich kann das nur empfehlen und irgendwie ist es doch auch mal nett wenn man sowas digitales macht wie einen podcast zu hören etwas so analogisch zu machen wie notizen holt euch den pot roll zettel und jetzt wünsche ich viel spaß mit der ausgabe des aktuellen tribünengesprächs hallo und herzlich willkommen zum tribünengespräch nummer drei das hier ist der rasen funkt mein namen ist maxa kubost etge netzer bei twitter und wir haben heute ein thema bei dem es besonders bitter ist dass dieses format Ich glaube, dass die Welt noch kein Intro hat, denn ganz viele andere Podcasts, über die wir heute reden, haben Intrennen oder Intros oder Intro-Ety. Ihr könnt das mal googeln und mir dann Bescheid geben. Wir wollen heute über Fußballpodcasts reden. Wir wollen euch die Sommerpause etwas verkürzen. Und wenn ihr das im Winter hört, auch gerne die Winterpause. Und ich habe zwei sehr kompetente Gäste zu diesem Thema eingeladen. Und zwar zum einen Klaas Reese. Hallo Klaas. Und in der anderen Seite der Box Maik Lindemeyer.
Absolut sympathischer Typ auf jeden Fall.
Genau, die reden über den Bundesligaspieltag, ein Format, was Rasenfunk hören eventuell bekannt ist von der Schlusskonferenz. Und die tun das in einer sehr angenehmen Art und Weise, wie ich finde. Es gibt dieses Setup durchaus noch öfter. Dafür verweise ich gerne nochmal auf die Podroll, die wir veröffentlichen. Allerdings mag ich die Art und Weise, welche Themen bei Reingemacht besprochen werden und manche auch eben nicht. Und da wird eben in wohltuender Art und Weise manches Thema dann doch mal ausgespart. Alles was – also ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel bei Facebook heute vorbeifliegend sehen. Jetzt können alle Leute dann raten, wann wir aufgenommen haben, dass am letzten Wochenende anscheinend sechs Bundesliga oder große Fußballprofis am selben Tag geheiratet haben. Und dann halt eine Bildergalerie mit den tollsten Hochzeiten. Und solche Themen will ich halt nicht in dem Podcast hören. Ist auch super, dass ich jetzt gerade drüber rede.
Ja gut, aber man muss ja mal fragen, was du meinst, was nicht besprochen wird. Hätte ja auch sein können, dass es darum geht, dass bestimmte Vereine einfach ausgeklammert werden.
Ach so, nein. Es werden durchaus alle Vereine behandelt. Natürlich mit einer gewissen Nähe zu Hannover und HSV, aber bei beiden Vereinen konnte man ja vor allem die letzte Saison nicht erleben, um sich ohne sich irgendwann während der Saison auch mal davon zu distanzieren. Also das konnte man sich sehr gut anhören. Und ja, was ich eben meinte, war eben, dass viele Bildthemen ausgelassen werden. Und ich brauche jetzt ehrlich gesagt, wenn es jetzt kein Fußballjournalist ist, der nicht die Primära Division jeden Spieltag verfolgt, dann brauche ich ehrlich gesagt keine 30-minütige Einschätzung zu der Wahrscheinlichkeit, ob Dick Riesmann zu Bayern wechselt. Das erwarte ich von Hobbypodcastern nicht. Und so was kriegt man bei reingemacht eben nicht. Die bleiben schön bei den Dingen, die sie glauben einzuschätzen. Und das ist immer sehr interessant. Maik, du hast noch was auf der Liste. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das jetzt anmoderieren soll.
Lass mich das einfach machen. Ich habe vor 8, 9 Jahren das letzte Mal Doppelpass gesehen. Das ist diese Sendung auf einem Nischen-Sender in Deutschland, die furchtbar schlecht ist, die aber leider immer noch wöchentlich unfassbare Einschaltquoten erzielt. Ich weiß nicht, wie hoch die sind, aber sie sind auf jeden Fall zu hoch. Und leider auch auf Twitter immer noch viel zu viel Wahrnehmbarkeit erfährt. Also ich finde es nach wie vor unfassbar, dass man sich darüber echauffiert, wie schlecht die Sendung ist, weil das sollte doch jeder wissen. Umso glücklicher war ich, als vor ungefähr einem Jahr eine Sendung da sich im Podcastbereich platziert hat, die das Ganze in Gut machen will und inhörbar und die heißt Rasenfunk. Finde ich total klasse, wird von einem jungen Herrn moderiert, der sich, habe ich zumindest das Gefühl, jedes Mal unfassbar vorbereitet und der dann meistens zwei oder drei Gäste hat, aus verschiedenen Vereinen, die meistens dann auch zu dem jeweiligen Verein sehr kompetent was erzählen können. Aber es wird eben nicht nur der jeweilige Verein besprochen, der ist natürlich dann Schwerpunkt, aber man spricht halt über das Gesamte, was an dem Spieltag leider nur in der ersten Bundesliga passiert ist. Und ja, hat so damit nochmal einen schönen runden Abschluss. In den allermeisten Fällen ist es sogar so, dass ich morgens am Montag den mir herunterladen kann und dazu in der Bahn dann den Kicker nochmal durchblätter. Und das ist natürlich eine, ja, Synergie ist unglaublich. Win-Win-Situation klasse. Gefällt mir sehr gut. Und das, was wir eben gesagt haben, der ganze Bildscheiß findet da eben auch nicht statt. Also es ist es wird halt auf Fußball sich reduziert. Es kommen je nach Gast dann auch mal ein paar Fan- Themen rein, was mich jetzt persönlich meistens sogar noch mehr interessiert als der Fußballpart. Aber es ist halt keine Mats Hummels Hochzeit.
Ja, ich bin unfassbar rot geworden. Vielen Dank. Das mit der Vorbereitung lasse ich einfach so dahingestellt. Vielleicht aber auch der Grund, warum wir nur über die erste Liga reden, weil ich will nur über Sachen reden.
Verstehe ich.
Ja, da müsste ich auch noch die zweite Liga mehr angucken und ich schaffe es ehrlich gesagt zeitlich jetzt schon nicht. Aber bevor das zu egoman wird, findet ihr auch, dass es erstaunlich ist, dass es in diesem Fanbereich keinen übergreifenden Podcast gibt?
Wie meinst du das jetzt?
Also das verschiedene Verein? Ja, der sich mit Fan-Themen beschäftigt. Also nur als Beispiel hatte ich mal als Idee, aber ich schaffe es nicht, sorry. Ist einfach gerade nicht mehr drin im Zeitbudget. Aber jedes Wochenende Fans, Auswärtsfahrer, Dauerkarteninhaber, wer auch immer, wer man halt so kennt, verschiedene Vereine zusammenschalten und einfach mit denen nur über den Spieltag aus Fan-Sicht reden. Also was habt ihr bei der Anreise erlebt? Gab es irgendwelche tollen Choreos, die euch aufgefallen sind? Und so quasi diesen Bereich abfrühstücken, aus dem Gedanken heraus, dass mich immer stört, dass Fan-Themen immer nur dann in den Mainstream-Medien thematisiert werden, wenn es Probleme gibt. Also immer dann, wenn halt mal Pyros fliegen oder wenn halt irgendwelche Plätze gestürmt werden, dann werden Fan-Themen thematisiert, aber eben nie positiv besetzt. Und ich finde, das fehlt so ein bisschen. Ich finde es schade, dass das keiner macht.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das Problem ist, dass es schwierig ist, dann auch aus den verschiedensten Fan-Szenen Leute zu finden, die sich dann halt auch wirklich da drüber austauschen können, dass das dann halt auch irgendwie Hand und Fuß hat, vielleicht. Also weil du ja, du bist ja dann schon auch auf deinen eigenen Verein irgendwie beschränkt erstmal und musst dann gucken über – ich weiß nicht, da gibt es da verschiedene Foren und Seiten, wo man die Sachen dann findet. Also ob man sowas dann jede Woche machen kann, weiß ich nicht, aber so prinzipiell ist das natürlich recht. Also das ist ja auch eine Sache, die ich bei so einem Podcast wie die Milan Ton dann halt auch super finde, dass ich da dann aus deren Fan-Szene halt auch mal sowas mitkriege. Man kriegt ja halt, wie du schon sagst, die negativen Sachen, die hört man immer sehr schnell. Aber was positiv drum rum passiert, das fällt ja sehr oft einfach unter den Tisch. Oder ist halt eine Kurzmeldung in irgendeinem Lokalblatt. Was ja halt wirklich sehr schade ist, weil ja gerade auch aus den Fan-Szenen immer sehr, sehr viel Positives passiert.
Genau. Und das muss ja auch nicht immer die riesen Choreos sein, ich glaube. Man kennt das ja selber, man erlebt so viele lustige Geschichten auf dem Weg ins Stadion und dafür muss man nicht mal auswärts fahren, das reicht oft sogar auf dem Weg zu Heimspielen. Irgendwie wäre es schon nett, da so ein Format zu haben. Vielleicht hört das ja irgendjemand, der sagt, da habe ich Bock drauf und ich bin auch gut vernetzt und dann kann man das mal machen.
Also ich würde das direkt Mike auftragen, eigentlich.
Ich hätte auch total Bock zu, aber ich habe da keine Zeit für. Und ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich, es hat zwei Komponenten. Zum einen überlege mal, wie lange es gedauert hat, bis sich so eine Sendung wie der Rasenfunk-Liga übergreifend gebildet hat, die sich auf das Sportliche beschränkt und wirklich alle Spiele abdeckt und das auch noch in einem annehmbaren Rahmen tut. Also ich kenne jetzt zum Beispiel das Reingemacht nicht. Ich will denen nicht zu nahe treten, die sind bestimmt auch toll, aber hat mich halt nicht erreicht. Und dann ist es natürlich nochmal schwieriger, und das hat Klaas eben so ein bisschen angedeutet, auch glaubhafte Positionen zu den einzelnen Fanszenen zu vertreten, weil jetzt gerade wenn wir über Fan-Kurven, über Fan-Themen sprechen, kommst du an den Ultras nicht vorbei. Und die Ultras sind in Sachen Öffentlichkeitsarbeit Auftreten nach außen ja doch eine sehr spezielle Gruppe. Und die, glaube ich, würdest du schwierig in so ein Format reinbekommen und dann auch noch wöchentlich wechselnd. Also das stelle ich mir sehr schwer vor. Ich würde das total klasse finden, wenn es sowas gibt, bin ich total bei dir. Aber auch da muss es halt eine Person geben, die das federführend in die Hand nimmt. Und das dann muss ja gar nicht wöchentlich, wäre ja auch monatlich schon schön. Ja ich glaube, da wird es dann auch schwierig mit der Akzeptanz, dass du da tatsächlich auch dann Leute rein kriegst, die sich zusammen an einen Tisch setzen und das auch noch regelmäßig machen bei einer neutralen Instanz, die das dort präsentiert. Also es ist zum Beispiel total leicht, Punkte gegen etwas zu finden und ich höre mich gerade selber ungern das sagen. Aber ich habe so meine Bedenken, dass das klappt. Ich würde mich aber umso mehr freuen, wenn es dann doch geschieht.
Vor allen Dingen, es wäre ja sehr erfolgsversprechend, wenn man hört, dass die Erfolgsfans allein auf YouTube mit einem Ultra-Gespräch, was waren es? 140.000 Videozeiten.
Also Was aber auch sehr kontroverse Reaktionen hervorgerufen hat. Also da gab es unter anderem sogar Morddrohungen gegen den Moderator. Ehrlich gesagt kriege ich es gerade nicht mehr ganz zusammen. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie öffentlich ich darüber reden soll. Er hat das aber, glaube ich, auch mal thematisiert. Es ist ein schwieriges Feld. Ich sehe das schon auch. Ich sehe auch die vielen Sachen, die dagegen sprechen. Ich finde aber ehrlich gesagt auch nicht, dass das nur Ultras sein müssten. Mir ist es zum Beispiel im Rasenfunk aufgefallen, dass es für mich als jemanden, der schon viel mitbekommt, aber eben doch nicht alles, auch schon viel geholfen hat, einfach mal mit einem – in Anführungszeichen – normalen Hannover-Fan über die Ultraszene zu reden. Und dann darf man da natürlich trotzdem nicht jedes Wort auf die Waagschale legen. Und es gibt bestimmt Ultras, die sagen würden, Moment mal, der hat unsere Position gar nicht richtig wiedergegeben. Ja, aber die könnten ja dann auch in so eine Sendung kommen. Also ich finde, das müssen auch nicht immer nur die Ultras sein, weil die sind halt zwar die am besten organisiertes, aber halt auch sehr heterogenste Masse eigentlich an Fans. Egal. Also ich wollte jetzt eigentlich auch nicht so ein eigenes Thema aufmachen. Aber wenn das jemand da draußen hört, der Bock auf sowas hat, bitte mach's. Es fehlt. Ich schenke dir auch den Namen Kurvendiskussion, habe ich mir dafür ausgedacht.
Alter Mathematiker.
Ja, finden vielleicht auch nur manche Leute lustig. Ich fand den wahnsinnig witzig, als es mir eingefallen ist. Es gab den Namen vor dem Format, aber ich kann es nicht machen. Es tut mir leid. Es geht einfach nicht.
Dann lass uns nochmal kurz über diesen, wie heißt das, Rasenfunk sprechen. Ich muss mich da dem Lob mal kurz noch anhängen, auch wenn das bestimmt ganz ungeprägt ist. Ja, aber ich finde es auch gut, dass da Leute die Möglichkeit bekommen, sozusagen über ihre Arbeit hinaus, also irgendwelche Journalisten, die in beschränkten Artikeln sich immer kurz fassen müssen, dann halt ihre Sicht der Dinge auch mal ausformulieren dürfen. Das finde ich höchst spannend und das war halt auch so ein Punkt, was einfach gefehlt hat. Also von daher, ich habe es dir ja schon in dem Rasenfunk-Hardcore- Mach mal weiter, auch wenn es sehr aufwendig ist und wenn du dir vielleicht irgendwann nochmal jemanden suchst, der es alle zwei, drei Wochen für dich übernimmt, aber bloß nicht einschlafen lassen mag.
Mal gucken. Wir haben es schon hinkriegen. Vielen Dank für das Kompliment. Übrigens hat man das manchen Journalisten auch angemerkt, dass die es sehr angenehm fanden, mal keine Zeichenbeschränkung zu haben. Da konnte ich mich auch durchaus mal fünf Minuten auf Mute stellen, kurz nochmal den Müll rausbringen, Zeitung reinholen, gucken, was der Dopa eigentlich so gesagt hat und dann wieder unmuten und die nächste Frage, natürlich geschlossene Frage, klar, meine Spezialität anstellen, egal. Ah, jetzt wird es viel zu sehr auf Rasenfunk bezogen. Deswegen, Klaas, du hast noch einen Podcast genannt in der Vorbereitung, bei dem man vom Titel her gar nicht denken würde, dass es fußballbezogen ist.
Du meinst den Vorecheck?
Genau.
You'll never talk alone schreibt er in seiner – also Christoph Fetzer ist da der Macher, ist Sportkommentator und hat halt da sich seinen eigenen Podcast gebaut. Ist ein breiteres Themesprechlung. Also es geht auf der einen Seite viel um Eishockey, NHL, DEL. Da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, habe ich noch nicht so gehört, weil das nicht so meine Sparte ist. Aber was ich öfter und gerne höre, sind die Gespräche über die Bundesliga, über die Primärdivision und auch über die Champions League. Weil diese Gespräche halt immer so zwischen 10 und 60 Minuten sich sehr ausführlich über halt ein Thema aussprechen. Also da wird dann zum Beispiel, also das fand ich, beim Champions League Finale fand ich super. Da hat er ein Gespräch gemacht über den FC Barcelona, eins über Juventus Turin und eins über den Schiedsrichter. Immer 45 Minuten lang. Und danach war ich super vorbereitet auf das Champions League Finale. Also meine Empfehlung für den Vorecheck.
Dem kann ich mich auch anschließen. Fetzi E super Typ. Ich weiß gar nicht, hatte ich ihn schon mal im Rasenfunk zu Gast? Er steht zumindest auf dem sehr umfangreichen Gästelistedokument, das ich habe. Das heißt, wenn er noch nicht zu Gast war, wird er mal irgendwann sein, wenn er sich nicht wehrt. Dem kann man auch bei Twitter folgen. Fetzi6. Ja. Er moderiert, glaube ich, unter anderem bei Laula1TV und Sport1FM, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Da kann man ihn hören.
Um es nochmal zu sagen. Ja, ist echt ganz gut. Nur der veröffentlicht irgendwie so komisch über Soundcloud. Das finde ich immer so ein bisschen schwierig. Die Sachen zu abonnieren. Aber gut, anderes Thema.
Ich muss dem vielleicht mal persönlich sagen. Wobei, wäre auch ein guter Check, ob er es hört. Ach komm, wir sagen ihm nichts. Und warten mal, bis er weggeht.
Ich wollte es einfach mal so jetzt hier streuen. Jeder Podcaster sollte sich mal die Gedanken darüber machen, wie einfach oder schwierig es ist, ihn zu abonnieren. Und das einfach mal irgendwie testen lassen.
Wobei man da auch sehr schnell frustriert sein kann. Also wenn man bei iTunes nach Bundesliga sucht, findet man zum Beispiel den Rasenfunk irgendwo auf Platz 97. Hinter 80 deaktivierten und alten Podcasts. Maik, du hast jetzt gerade schon einen in der Runde zum Erröten gebracht, weil du ihn mit Lob überschüttet hast. Jetzt darfst du es auch mit dem zweiten machen. Wir kommen zu dem Podcast, die sich einem Thema widmen.
Ich muss trotzdem nochmal bei dem Erröten deinerseits bleiben, nämlich das Tribünengespräch zumindest nur erwähnen, weil ich gerade diese Doping-Sendung mit Jonathan Sachse unfassbar großartig fand. Und das ja doch nochmal als eigener Podcast zumindest in der Suche auch läuft. Also, dass der Formhalber zumindest erwähnt haben und auch wenn da bisher ja erst dann mit heute drei richtige Sendungen herausgekommen sind, plus die Nullnummer. Das andere war der Journalist im Wintertrainingslager, was ich ja so quer gehört habe, da kann ich nicht so viel zu sagen. Aber die Doping-Sendung hat mich begeistert. Fand ich ganz, ganz großartig, weil das einfach ein Thema ist, dem man sich in der Komplexität sehr schwer nähern kann. Und da hat mir diese Sendung doch sehr viel augenöffnende Momente beschert. Aber kommen wir zu Collinas Erben und damit dann die Errüttung anderer Seite. Der Letzten ist, die haben halt keine Ahnung von Mode. Die erzählen ständig Sachen über Schiedsrichter, Klamotten, wo ich nur um den Kopf schütteln kann. Aber ansonsten ist es echt nicht schlecht. Ich habe die erste Sendung, glaube ich, von Ihnen gehört. Und das war diese Nummer eins mit den Regelerklärungen. Und da ich nun selber seit meinem sechsten Lebensjahr an Fußball gespielt habe, habe ich immer gedacht, Fußballregeln kann mir keiner so schnell was vormachen. Aber ich war halt nie Schiedsrichter. Und ich bin ein leidenschaftlicher Schiedsrichter-Beschimpfer. Pflege eine Hassliebe mit Dennis Aitekin. Und da sind unfassbar viele Sachen bei gewesen, wo ich gedacht habe, ach, Quatsch. So ist das also. Spannend. Hab mich immer gefragt schon nach der ersten, nach der zweiten Sendung, gut, wie lange wollen die das wohl machen? Also dieser Alex Feuerherd und der Klaas Reese ist ja auch ganz launig, aber irgendwann sind die Regeln halt weg und dann können die nicht mehr. Ich glaube, ihr seid mir den Regeln immer noch nicht durch. Habt inzwischen keine Ahnung auch über 50 Sendungen. Und aus meiner Sicht ist das super, weil ihr besprecht halt seitdem immer die Sachen, die am Wochenende gerade passiert sind. Und auch da, als das begann, habe ich gedacht, irgendwann hat sich das ja abgenutzt. Ich meine, du kannst ja nicht jede Woche über die Elfmeterentscheidung sprechen. Und siehe da? Doch, man kann. Und es wird nicht langweilig. Es ist natürlich auch in den beiden Personen begründet, die sich inzwischen wirklich die Bälle wunderbar zuspielen. Und also für mich wirklich einer der Podcasts, wo ich sage, da versäume ich keine Folge. Ich sehr zu meiner Schande hänge ich momentan deutlich hinterher. Also es sind noch die Folgen 63, glaube ich, oder sowas, die ich noch aktuell den ich lausche. Aber das ist halt auch der große Vorteil. Collinas Erben ist tatsächlich relativ zeitlos. Also natürlich ist es empfehlenswert, die entsprechenden Spielszenen nochmal so ein bisschen vor Augen zu haben, wenn die da jetzt skizziert werden. Aber gerade Alex ist es auch zu eigen, eine sehr bildhafte Sprache zu führen und die Sachen nochmal sehr schön zu beschreiben. Und von daher, wenn man die Sache denn zumindest einmal vor drei, vier Monaten auch gesehen hat, dann kommt sie einem sehr schnell wieder ins Gedächtnis und dann kann man dem auch folgen. Und nichtsdestotrotz ist es natürlich da auch super ergänzt durch den Twitter-Account, der dann auch während der Spieltage ständiger Anlaufpunkt ist. Und das, denke ich, hat sich wirklich sehr, sehr in der deutschen Twitter- und Podcastszene etabliert.
Denke ich auch. Ich hätte da eine Frage an Klaas noch, weil ich habe nämlich den Eindruck, dass unheimlich viel Vorbereitung gerade auch in der Schilderung der Szenen besteht. Schreibst du dir das vorher auf, weil das immer so punktgenau formuliert ist? Bitte sag, dass du es aufschreibst.
In den allerallermeisten Fällen ist es Vorbereitung. Das ging ja anders nicht. Also wenn... Also mir geht es ja oft so, dass ich bestimmte Szenen nach zwei Wochen schon nicht mehr im Kopf habe. Deswegen schreiben wir uns dann, wenn es passiert, wird das immer direkt notiert. Ich glaube, sonst wäre das nicht möglich. Und weil es ja genau der Punkt ist, wenn du bestimmte Sachen nicht gesehen hast und es wird nicht vorher nochmal erklärt, worum es geht, dann wird es halt nicht funktionieren.
Gott sei Dank, weil wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin, ich bin auch ein großer Fan eurer Show, aber ich habe euch zwischenzeitlich nicht gehört, weil es mich tatsächlich aggressiv gemacht hat, wie rhetorisch gewandt Alex ist. Das hat mich auf die Palme gebracht, dass der jeden noch so langen Schachtelsatz mit dem richtigen Verb zu Ende gebracht hat. Das war purer Neid angesichts meiner eigenen Moderatorinleistung, aber tatsächlich war das einer der Gründe, warum ich euch mal so drei, vier Folgen lang habe ich euch tatsächlich nicht gehört, weil ich irgendwie mir gedacht habe, ich kann mir jetzt nicht wieder so wohlfeile Formulierungen anhören. Dann noch ausgestattet mit lateinischen Zitaten, die wahrscheinlich alle stimmen, keine Ahnung. Weiß ich nicht. Aber ihr habt euch auch sehr schön eingespielt. Ihr seid so ein bisschen für mich Waldorf und Statler der Podcastszene.
Auf dem Balkon sitzen. Das sollten wir vielleicht mal machen.
Schon so ein bisschen. Und es gibt Wörter, die meines Wissens nach erst verwendet werden, seitdem es euren Podcasts gibt. So auf Platz eins dazu Zeitlupenwissen.
Kannte ich vorher auch nicht. Das sind so Schiedsrichtersachen. Also für mich ist das ja auch immer noch ein Buch mit nicht mehr sieben Siegeln, aber immer noch vier oder drei. Ist ja so eine ganz eigene Szene und das, was Maik da vorher erzählt hat, ich hätte es ja auch nie gedacht, dass wir das so lange machen können. Dass der Podcast noch läuft, ist ja wirklich auch den Hörern einfach nur zu verdanken, die sich immer wieder melden. wir bereiten das halt schon relativ ausführlich vor. Die einzelnen Folgen. Und haben dann ja immer unsere Skripte, die so drei bis sieben Seiten lang sind. Dann tut es mir natürlich sehr gut, wenn der Maik zwar keine Ahnung von Mode hat, aber trotzdem ganz nette Worte findet.
Werdet ihr viel von Schiedsrichtern gehört?
Ja, viel oder wenig. Es ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig. Wir waren ja da mal in der Schiedsrichterzeitung. Es gibt ja eine eigene Schiedsrichterzeitung vom DFB, wo so ein Portrait über uns drin war. Seitdem ist es glaube ich deutlich mehr geworden und wir kriegen halt auch relativ viel Rückmeldung von Schiedsrichtern. Aber wie gesagt, was da viel ist, ich meine es gibt ja auch ein paar tausend Schiedsrichter in Deutschland, die hören uns halt nicht alle, aber so ein paar hören uns schon. Und für die ist das dann glaube ich sowieso eine kleine Fortbildung. Wo Maik dann sagt, ich höre Englisch für meinen Job, so hören die das halt so für ihren Hobby als Fortbildung, den Podcast, um dann von Alex in sein ja, du hast recht, manchmal etwas zu lang setzen.
Es war keine Kritik, es war Neid.
Naja, also ich versuche ihn ja manchmal schon so ein bisschen auch anzutreiben. Das kriegt ihr ja nicht so mit. Aber er ist ja auch so ruhig. Das ist ja Wahnsinn. Ich glaube, das ist einfach, wenn du so lange Schiedsrichter warst, hast so viel erlebt, dann kann der vor dir einer rumturnen und dir Zeichen geben, dass du mal hinmachen sollst. Du ziehst das einfach durch.
Ich glaube, ihr solltet immer drüber nachdenken, das doch hauptberuflich machen zu wollen. Das eine Einnahmequelle wäre, ihr geht auf Tour. Und Tour bedeutet, Alex leitet einfach ein Hobbyfußballspiel, weil ich glaube, es gibt ganz viele Hörer, mich eingeschlossen, die ihn wahnsinnig gerne mal auf dem Platz erleben würden.
Ja, wäre eine Idee. Wäre ja für mich dann ganz easy. Ich könnte dann draußen stehen und die Tomaten verkaufen, um ihn zu bewerfen oder so. Nein, mal gucken. Also die Idee, mit dem mal irgendwie was außerhalb zu machen, die haben wir tatsächlich. Da gibt es auch schon erste Überlegungen. Dann noch einen Spiel pfeifen zu lassen, finde ich eigentlich ganz gut. Die Idee gefällt mir. Werde ich ihm mal vorschlagen.
Also ich würde es total gern sehen, weil er gibt ja immer mal wieder so Hinweise darauf, wie er so als Schiedsrichter aktiv war und welche Ansprache er gewählt hat. Ich würde das gerne mal sehen und eigentlich würde ich auch gerne mitspielen. Und ich glaube, ich würde immer mal wieder Dinge einbauen, die ich normalerweise in meinem Fußballspiel weggelassen habe. Schwalben. Noch mehr gegen den Schiri meckern. Ich habe immer viel gemeckert, aber tatsächlich auch, ich hatte viel mit Schiedsrichtern zu tun, die nicht alle Regeln kannten, das muss ich echt mal sagen. Und im Nachhinein, ich weiß nur, dass ich bei einer Folge die Bäcker-Faus gemacht habe, als ich es gehört habe, als ich beim Einkaufen war, das war ein bisschen skurril, war an der Gemüse, am Gemüse stand, weil ihr nämlich einen Fall erklärt habt, der genauso bei mir in einem C-Klasse-Spiel vorgekommen ist und das Tor wurde gewertet und ich habe gesagt, es ist abseits. Und der Schiri selber hat gesagt, ne, da kam ja von eurem Mann, dabei war es angeschossene Tore, egal. Toller Podcast, Klaas, wirklich.
Ja, danke für die Blumen. Hört man gern.
Macht mal weiter so, bitte. Ist Collinas Abend das Spiel deines Lebens?
Eine traumhaft delingische Überleitung. Ich werde nie ein richtiger Schiedsrichter. Dazu bin ich zu sehr noch Fußballer. Aber das Spiel meines Lebens ist ja auch der Name einer wunderbaren Sendung. Bei meinem Sportradio ist ein sehr schönes, zeitloses Format. Da kann man sich auch ganz alte Folgen noch anhören. Es sind immer so eine gute halbe Stunde lang. Da kommen dann Gäste, die über ihr absolutes Lieblingsspiel sprechen. Da ist dann zum Beispiel mal einer gewesen, der hat über das Spiel Meppen gegen Frankfurt gesprochen. Einer von euch beiden weiß Bescheid warum?
Traurigerweise nicht, nein.
Meppen hat damals Frankfurt 6 zu 1 geschlagen, 1996. Da fallen Namen wie Brazas, Stepanovich, Bindewald, Dickhaut. Es macht schon Spaß, darüber etwas erzählt zu bekommen. Es geht aber auch nicht nur über dieses eine Spiel, sondern es ging in dem Fall auch über Meppen. Da wurde auch mal erzählt, dass ein gewisser Christian Klaasen, Jürgen Klopp Knoten in die Beine gespielt hat. Er hat in drei Toren 15 Minuten gemacht und Jürgen Klopp wurde ausgewechselt. Also sehr schöne Anekdoten dabei. Oder es gibt doch mal eine Erklärung zu dem Spiel. Lok Leipzig gegen Bordeaux von 1987 vor über 100.000 Zuschauern im Zentralstadion. Wirklich sehr schön. Oder Trainer Frank Bade war da. Der hat über Deutschland gegen Kamerun bei der WM 2002 gesprochen, wo ich niemals gedacht hätte, dass das das Lieblingsspiel von irgendjemand oder das Spiel des Lebens von jemand sein kann. Und die Sendung lebt halt einfach auch sehr schön vom Moderator. Andreas Thies moderiert das sehr, sehr angenehm, ist immer sehr gut vorbereitet. Und das ist wirklich so eine Sendung, die würde ich jedem ans Herz legen. Und er soll einfach bei Folge eins anfangen und dann alles durchhören. Macht sehr viel Spaß.
Womit wir ja eigentlich bei einem großen Themenkomplex angekommen sind, denn das Mein-Sport-Radio hat ja schon im Namen, dass es sich mit sehr vielen unterschiedlichen Aspekten des Sports befasst. Wollen wir vielleicht mal, wenn wir jetzt dann so auf die Erstliga-Podcasts gucken, einfach mal anfangen mit all den Formaten, die man bei mein-sport-radio.de findet. Vielleicht müssen wir dann noch kurz erklären, was das ist. Klaas, fühlst du dich dazu in der Lage?
Ich kann es versuchen. Also, ich glaube, mein-sport-radio ist die Idee, dass halt eigentlich jeder mitmachen kann, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Also, jeder kann über Sport da eine eigene Sendung starten, mit Hilfe, hat ja Maik vorhin schon mal gesagt. Also, wenn man da auf mein-sport-radio.de geht und sich bei denen meldet, dann kriegt man auch Tipps, wie man an der Sendung stemmen kann. Und da haben sich dann halt Leute gefunden, die über die unterschiedlichsten Vereine Sendung machen. Also, zum Beispiel über Augsburg, da gibt es eine Sendung, die heißt auf die Zirbelnuss. Und da gibt es dann halt so eine kleine Gruppe von bis zu fünf Leuten, glaube ich, waren das, und die skypen dann. Und diese Sendung wird dann aufgezeichnet. Das wird dann an mein-sport-radio irgendwie übermittelt. Die bauen das dann in ihr Radioprogramm ein, mit Musik und so weiter. Und da gibt es halt 24 Stunden am Tag nur Sportsendung bei mein-sport-radio.de. Ja, und wenn ich auf die Zirbelnuss schon erwähnt habe, dann würde ich das auch ganz gerne empfehlen. Augsburg ist ja so eine Mannschaft. Ja, da wurde immer gesagt, ja, große Überraschung. Und wie toll das doch ist über die letzten Jahre. Aber so richtig viel über den Verein und immer, oder was Neues über die Spielphilosophie oder über die Spieler kriegt man ja nicht mit. Und da ist so eine Sendung natürlich sehr schön, weil das Leute sind, deren Lieblingsverein der FCA ist. Und vor allen Dingen die Moderatorin, Christel heißt sie, wenn ich das richtig fahre, die war zwischendurch auch mal weg. Aber meistens moderiert sie das sehr sympathisch, findet immer schöne Überleitungen, großes Fußballwissen bindet alle Leute irgendwie in diese Sendung ein und da erfährt man dann halt was über irgendwelche Links-Verteidiger, von denen man nie was gehört hat und die jetzt am Ende der Saison große Angebote aus aller Welt bekommen vielleicht. Also mir macht das sehr viel Spaß. Auf die Zirbelnuss als Empfehlung von mir noch. Was hört ihr gerne bei Mein Sport Radio?
Ich fange mal an mit dem Kritikpunkt, den sich Mein Sport Radio aktuell noch stellen muss, nämlich man kann nur den einen Mein Sport Radio Account abonnieren bei Podcasts. Und das ist tatsächlich mein großes Problem. Und deswegen höre ich meinsportradio.de immer, wenn ich am PC sitze und irgendwas mal nebenbei machen muss. Und dann höre ich das tatsächlich auf der Webseite. Ich habe mir den jetzt in mein Smartphone auch schon mal reingespielt, aber dafür bin ich zu doof, zu umständlich. Weiß ich nicht, das kriege ich nicht hin. Deswegen wollte ich gerade noch ansetzen bei Das Spiel meines Lebens. War da von euch schon mal jemand zu Gast?
Ich bin froh, dann müsste ich mir überlegen, was das Spiel meines Lebens war.
Genau, ich nehme mich auch. Ich habe so zwei, drei Spiele, auf die ich mich noch nicht einigen konnte, und deswegen höre ich die auch total gerne. Aber wenn man dann diese unfassbar lange Liste im Podcastplayer seiner Wahl hat, da ist es halt schwer, die da zu finden. Und ich glaube, gerade aktuell das Spiel meines Lebens ist da in den ersten 200 gar nicht dabei. Oder ich habe es halt übers Gold, das kann natürlich auch sein. Und da tue ich mich mit denen noch sehr schwer. Also von daher ist das jetzt auch gleichzeitig die Aufforderung an den XXL-Honk doch mal den versprochenen, demnächst vorfindbaren, verschiedenen Feed für die jeweiligen Sendungen endlich umzusetzen. Schönen Gruß.
Dann kann ich ja vielleicht, nachdem du ja quasi schon indirekt gesagt hast, dass es dir ein bisschen schwerfällt da reinzuhören. Ich finde auch, dass es so mit der deprimierendste Podcast ist, weil man da immer nur 99 in der Podcast-App stehen hat für die noch nicht gehörten Folgen. Und 99 nur deshalb, weil es bei 99 aufhört, zumindest in meiner Podcast-App. Trotzdem höre ich immer mal wieder gerne rein, weil ich die Leute sehr mag, die da mitmachen. Was ich sehr gerne höre und hiermit empfehlen möchte, ist der HSV-Talk. Man mag es vielleicht nicht glauben, wenn man mich in der Schlusskonferenz hört, aber ich höre mir regelmäßig einen HSV-Podcast an. Und viele der Meinungen, die ich über den HSV habe, hole ich mir auch über diesen Podcast, bilde ich die mir selbst. Verrückt. Nee, kann ich sehr empfehlen. Ist immer höhenswert, auch mit tollen Gästen. Ich selbst durfte neulich mal zu Gast sein zum Thema Warum mag keiner den HSV? Keine Ahnung, warum man mich da eingeladen hat. Aber zusammen in einer total illustrieren Runde mit Oliver Fritsch von Zeit Online, mit Rollo Fuhrmann von Sky. Ach mein Gott, und jetzt vergesse ich den Dritten und tue ihm damit wahnsinnig unrecht. Der war auch sehr sympathisch. Ja, super. Ich habe den Namen vergessen. Ich hätte nicht damit anfangen sollen. Es war eine ganz tolle Runde, aber es ist wirklich höhenswertes Format und bringt so ein bisschen die Stärken von meinem Sportradio, von den einzelnen Podcasts auf den Punkt. Die Sendungen sind nie überbordend lang. Dadurch, dass sie in ein Internetradio-Programm eingefügt werden, sind das immer Themenblöcke, würde ich mal sagen, die 15 Minuten dauern und insgesamt dauern die einzelnen Folgen nie besonders lange. Und so gerne ich auch vier Stunden Podcasts höre, ist es immer sehr angenehm, zwischendurch was zu haben, was man auch mal einfach in einem Rutsch weghören kann. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir da geht, Klaas.
Ich bin eher der Fan von einem nicht formatierten Podcast. Also ich würde das eher als Schwäche bei manchen Sendungen anfügen, weil man hört dann so, da wird dann drüber gesprochen und auf einmal heißt es so, so und jetzt machen wir eine kurze Pause und dann geht es gleich weiter. Im Podcast ist diese Pause dann halt überhaupt nicht da. Es wird dann wieder anmoderiert. Mich nervt das eher zwischendurch. Aber gut, das ist halt die Entscheidung von meinem Sport, dass man sagt, wir wollen zwischendurch auch mal ein bisschen Musik spielen. Das ist natürlich für mich als reinen Podcastführer. Also ich höre meinsportradio.de eigentlich nur als Podcast. Ist das so ein bisschen schwierig. Zum Beispiel auch beim Hannover-liebt-Podcast, also noch so ein Podcast aus dieser MeinSportradio-Ecke. Da moderiert der Tobi das sehr souverän, ist sehr gut informiert und ist dann aber teilweise halt so, ich weiß nicht, ob die gezwungen sind oder wie die Ansage da ist, einfach dann auch mal irgendwo einen Cut zu setzen. Das ist so ein bisschen schade. Ansonsten Hannover-liebt natürlich über den besten Verein der Welt, über Hannover 96. Sehr meinungsstark.
Du hattest da gerade eine Wort-Wortschere drin. Du hast bester Verein der Welt und Hannover 96 gesagt.
Max, unterbrich mich bitte nicht.
Entschuldigung, wir schneiden das raus.
Bitte nicht. Nein, also auf jeden Fall sehr meinungsstarker Podcast. Es gibt teilweise ziemlich harte Urteile über Spieler mit ziemlich markigen Worten, die ich oftmals gar nicht teile. Aber ich finde es dann ganz gut, weil dann kann ich mich dann eher über die Leute aufregen, die das dann erzählen, als dass ich mich über die Spieler weiter aufregen muss, die 16 Spiele in Folge nicht gewonnen haben. Und das finde ich halt auch immer so ganz gut bei diesen Vereinspodcasts. Ich höre die dann immer ganz gerne. Wenn 96 dann zum Beispiel gegen Augsburg spielt, dann höre ich dann vermehrt vorher diesen Augsburg-Podcast sozusagen, um mich auf dieses Spiel auch selber vorzubereiten und mehr zu wissen. Und das ist ja generell, finde ich, auch so eine Stärke von diesem Podcast. Also ich muss ja nicht immer alle Podcasts über Bremen, Freiburg und Augsburg hören, aber in den Wochen, wo es dann darum geht, gegen diesen Verein oder auch in der Woche danach, wie bewerten die das Spiel, da sind sie dann besonders spannend. Also da, um vielleicht nochmal eine besondere Stärke der Podcasts nochmal herauszustellen, das finde ich sehr gut.
Definitiv. Und jetzt gerade haben sie auch ein wahnsinnig spannendes Format. Das ist jetzt sehr zeitbezogen, eigentlich gar nicht fürs Tribünengespräch geeignet. Ich sage es trotzdem. Felgenrale Ghost WM, Frauen WM. Also Ralf Gunnisch, den wir alle, da wir bei Twitter sehr aktiv sind, sehr schätzen und ihm folgen, spricht über die Frauen WM. Hör ich sehr gerne und ich glaube ihr auch.
Richtig. Ich kenne Ralf ja nun auch schon ein bisschen länger, dadurch, dass er ja mal bei meinem Verein gespielt hat und da auch mit dem Herzen, wie er ja durchaus häufig zu verstehen gibt, auch immer noch ist.
Dir gehört der FC St. Pauli?
Natürlich. Ich bin Mitglied.
Kannst du dann bitte das Sankt rausnehmen, da mache ich keinen Fehler mehr, wenn ich einfach nur von Pauli spreche. Ehrlich gesagt habe ich mir überlegt, ob ich das als Running Gag jetzt einbaue, dass ich immer, wenn ich über den VfL Pauli spreche oder die Spielvereinerung Pauli, immer es komplett falsch mache, dann wird das nicht mehr zum Vorwurf.
Ich finde das gut. Also Leute, die uns gezielt dissen wollen, korrigiere ich auch nicht. Also es ist egal, führt zu weit. Ja, also Ralf Gunther spricht über die Frauen-WM. Ich finde, das ist tatsächlich eine ganz großartige Idee gewesen, die mein Sportradio da hatte. Da, wie wir alle wissen, in sozialen Medien ja Frauenfußball immer noch sehr gerne belächelt ist, fast schon zu hübsch formuliert, also eher sehr abschätzig auf unterstem Niveau heruntergehandelt wird. Da jetzt jemanden zu nehmen, der gerade in diesen sozialen Medien ein gewisses Standing hat und positiv besetzt ist und als männlicher Fußballprofi natürlich auch jetzt ein gewisses Know-How einfach mal pauschal vorausgesetzt wird, dass der jetzt tatsächlich täglich über diese Frauenfußball-WM berichtet, finde ich, tut mein Sportradio sehr gut, weil es einfach das Gesamtangebot sehr bereich hat und ist eben auch durch die nach den einzelnen Spielen kleinen Häppchen von acht Minuten, wenn es jetzt einfach nur mal kurzer Zusammenfassung ist des einzelnen Spieltags, eben auch kurz mal zwischendurch zu genießen. Das muss man sich nicht zwingend runterladen, kann man aber eben auch. So eine Geschichte würde ich mir tatsächlich auch noch häufiger situationsbezogen zu anderen Formaten vorstellen können. Das finde ich tatsächlich klasse. Ich glaube, Ralf ist da jemand, der diesen neuen Medien sehr aufgeschlossen gegenüber ist. Von daher kommt da vielleicht noch mal was.
Sehr guter Moderator, wie ich finde, sagte er mit neidvoller Stimme.
Ich finde das auch. Er macht das sehr sympathisch auf jeden Fall und hat auch immer gute Gesprächsgäste da. Ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel die Folge über das Achtelfinale gehört. Ich habe gar nicht so viel Frauenfußball WM bisher geguckt, weil das ja teilweise doch ein bisschen später kam. Für mich war das zu spät, leider. Dann kamen dann wirklich Experten da rein. Ich weiß, Philipp Eitzinger war dann zum Beispiel da, der sich da aus Österreich sehr viel mit dem Frauenfußball beschäftigt. Da habe ich Sachen erfahren über den Frauenfußball, wo ich dachte, ja geil, habe ich nirgends gelesen bisher. Da ging es eigentlich immer nur darum, dass irgendwer geschrieben hat, darum ist Frauenfußball doof oder darum ist Frauenfußball toll. Aber so wirklich Inhaltliches leider ziemlich wenig. Das ist eigentlich wirklich etwas, wo sich mein Sportradio natürlich so eine Stärke entwickeln könnte. Dass man auch mal zwischendurch sagt, wir versuchen das Thema mal so ein bisschen von der anderen Seite anzugehen. In diesem Fall ist die Felgenralle Ghost WM ziemlich gut gelungen, auch wenn der Titel natürlich gewöhnungsbedürftig ist.
Ja, man muss ja dafür wissen, wer Felgenralle ist. Na gut, das kriegt man ja wohl dann hin. Ansonsten braucht man sowas auch nicht hören, ganz ehrlich. Auf jeden Fall ein super Typ. Vielleicht kriege ich ihn irgendwann mal für ein Tribünengespräch, wie es eigentlich ist, Fußballprofi zu sein. Mal gucken. Wenn das jemand hört, penetriert ihn mal bei Twitter. So lange nerven, bis er es macht. Ich habe bewusst dieses Reizwort gesetzt, um bestimmte Nutzergruppen anzusprechen. Immerhin ist Wochenende, da kann man auch ruhig mal rebellieren. Oder du schickst ihm eine SMS, Maik. Da bin ich jetzt neidisch drauf. Darüber reden wir später. Wir haben damit jetzt schon ein paar Formate von www.meinsportradio.de genannt, generell auch nicht nur auf Fußball bezogen. Also auch im Golf sehr unterwegs. Formel 1 Talk gibt's. Wer sich zusätzlich zu dem Autosfahren im Kreis und überholen sich nicht auch noch anderthalb Stunden anhören will, wie Experten sich darüber einig sind, dass es langweilig ist, wie die im Kreis fahren, kann das gerne tun. Nein, aber sehr gutes Programm, auch über den Fußball hinausgehend. Und damit könnten wir eigentlich den Bogen schlagen zu einem Podcast, den Maik vorhin schon kurz erwähnt hat, Sportradio 360.
Ich muss kurz unterbrechen, wir haben einen nämlich noch vergessen, den Füchseltalk.
Ach Gott, ja.
Darf ich, darf ich ihn nicht vergessen zu nennen. Fangen direkt mit einer Kritik an, die senden viel zu sporadisch, haben eine lange Pause gemacht zwischendurch, das fand ich nicht gut. Aber sonst drei, vier Leute, die über ihren eigenen Verein sehr schön kritisch diskutieren. Ich glaube, das sind so welche, die auch diesen Satz, ich finde ihn ja so fürchterlich, da wird ja immer gesagt, ja der SC Freiburg, bei denen ist nicht schlimm, wenn die eine zweite Liga absteigen, bei denen ist das Prinzip des Vereins oder so. Ich glaube, das finden die genauso doof wie ich. Auch Christian Streich wird da immer sehr schön kritisch beäugt, auch wenn die den eigentlich natürlich alles super finden, aber diese Saison lief ja dann auch nicht alles so richtig gut. So mit Automatismen oder auch die Transfers, die so getätigt wurden, lief ja nicht alles so super. Leider auch per Skype alles, was wir ja selber jetzt auch irgendwie nutzen. Das ist manchmal so ein bisschen anstrengend, aber sonst, ich glaube, sie nennen sich jetzt ab nächster Saison der erstklassigste Podcast der zweiten Liga und mindestens das würde ich auch unterstreichen. Sehr höherenswert, der Füchstetalk und damit auch die Aufforderung an die Macher. Ihr müsst jetzt wieder regelmäßiger sein. Ich höre euch gerne.
Oh, das wäre jetzt echt schlimm gewesen, wenn wir den vergessen hätten. Vielen, vielen Dank. Ich war mal als Gast angeladen, ist nicht zustande gekommen meinerseits. Wahrscheinlich wäre ich nie wieder eingeladen worden.
Das muss ich da jetzt aber in Schutz nehmen, weil die sind halt nur noch zweite Liga und die kommen halt später.
Ja, stimmt. Aber wir hatten ja gesagt, wir wollen meinen Sportradio, die ihr zusammenfassen. So wie wir auch über das Sportradio 360 reden wollen, obwohl es auch da nicht nur um Fußball geht. Um was geht es denn, Maik?
Ja, also Sportradio 360 klingt jetzt erstmal relativ ähnlich wie mein Sportradio, bietet aber nicht die Bandbreite. Und tatsächlich höre ich bei denen auch nur ein einziges Format, und das ist die Big Show. Und das war zusammen mit dem Textilvergehen dann auch, glaube ich, am Anfang das, was ich wirklich mit, wo ich mit Podcasts groß geworden bin, vor noch gar nicht so vielen Jahren, wo ich vielleicht auch zu oft dann zugehört habe, weil deren Sendungen gehen tatsächlich auch immer drei, vier Stunden. Er scheint in der Regel am Donnerstag Nachmittag und ist eine sehr, sehr illustre Zusammensetzung in der Regel von ein oder zwei Moderatoren im Münchner Studio. Oft auch dann irgendwie aus Sky zusammenhängen, also durchaus prominente Moderatoren dann auch. Und dann Gäste, die entweder sich tatsächlich aus Sportjournalisten zusammensetzen oder auch Sportlehrer, wobei das dann eher bei den nicht ganz so prominenten Sportarten passiert, aber zum Beispiel Heiner Brandt oder sowas ist dann da auch schon mal zu hören gewesen, wenn es um Handball ging, bedienen sich auch im Bereich Formel 1 gerne mal bei Leuten, die sich da im Podcast- oder Blogbereich sehr gut mit auskennen, haben da also auch keine Berührungsängste und ist tatsächlich der komplette Rundumschlag zum Sport. Und dadurch, dass es Donnerstag erscheint, in der Regel mit Ausblick aufs Wochenende, aber natürlich bei allem, was am vergangenen Wochenende oder im Bereich Champions League jetzt gerade auch passiert ist, dann natürlich immer mit einem kurzen Zurückblick auf das, was war. Und aufgrund der Länge und des wöchentlichen Erscheinens neige ich da auch zum sehr selektiven Hören. Was das Ganze recht einfaches macht, ist, dass der Fußball in der Regel am Anfang steht, sodass da die erste Stunde mit meistens bestritten wird. Und danach muss man dann halt gucken, je nach Vorliebe, was man dann an Basketball, Football, Eishockey, Formel 1 halt noch mitnehmen will und was nicht. Aber wie gesagt, das ist die Sendung, die auch in meinem Player immer sehr weit vorne und sehr regelmäßig aktualisiert wird.
Kommt bei dir da auch mal so eine Hektik auf? Also ich erlebe das bei mir selbst, wenn die Big Show da ist, dann muss man möglichst viel bis zum Wochenende gehört haben, weil danach wird es zum Teil obsolet und dann hält man es auch nicht durch, dann doch die ganzen drei Stunden fertig zu hören. Also bei mir rutscht quasi immer Donnerstagabend rutscht dann die Big Show rein, egal was ich vorher gehört habe. Davon höre ich dann so viel wie möglich, wenn ich die Zeit habe, damit ich noch ein bisschen was mitkriege. Also das ist so der hektischste Podcast von der Nutzungssituation hier für mich.
Na ja, da bin ich tiefenentspannt. Also ich höre mir sowas auch noch drei Wochen später an, auch wenn ich schon weiß, wie die Spiele ausgegangen sind.
Das hasse ich ja.
Aber das ist jetzt natürlich vielleicht auch wieder in der Person St. Pauli-Fan geschuldet. Wir machen uns von Ergebnissen ja generell frei. Und deswegen gedrosiert mich das. Also ich höre einfach den Leuten da gerne zu.
Fußball mit Zähnen ist irgendwie doof.
Aber das ist übrigens bei mir bei der Schlusskonferenz so. Wenn die dann montags draußen ist, muss ich auch mal schnell hören, weil wenn da noch ein Spieltag dazwischen war, dann verpasst man ja schon wieder viel, was ja mal sehr ärgerlich ist.
Ja, absolut. Deswegen gibt es auch das Tribünengespräch, was den Ansatz hatte, zeitloser zu sein, weil es mir selber auf den Nerv gegangen ist. Man steckt so viel Arbeit in eine Sendung. Und ich zwinge mich dazu, jede Sendung nochmal zu hören, um in der nächsten vielleicht besser zu werden in dem, was ich tue. Und denke mir dann selber manchmal, toll, jetzt hast du die nicht gehört. Egal. Aber Sportrate 360, sehr empfehlenswert. Man lernt auch, finde ich, sehr viel über Sportarten, die man nicht zum Blick hatte. Also, ich interessiere mich generell für sehr viel, aber im Tennisbereich habe ich mich gerade im Dahn-Tennis bisher nicht so ausgekannt. Ich fand auch immer, dass das – na, nee, will da eigentlich gar keine Wertung jetzt zu abgeben öffentlich. Aber zu solchen Bereichen lernt man sehr viel, auch zu sehr vielen Rennserien, die nicht Formel 1 heißen. Das kann ich auch jedem nur ans Herz legen, der vorhin bei meiner Formel 1 Kritik – ich bin selber eigentlich Formel 1 Fan – genickt hat. Dann lohnt sich auch die Big Show, denn da wird auch über alle Nesca-Serien und sonstigen Rennserien, die ich beim Namen gar nicht alle aufnennen kann, geredet, immer sehr interessant. Einziges Manko, Tonqualität oft noch schlechter als im Rasenfunk. Das muss man erstmal hinkriegen.
Also, teilweise abenteuerlich, oftmals auch Skype geschuldet, teilweise aber auch mit wichtigen Sportsteilnisten, die im Auto auf der Autobahn zwischen Frankfurt und Nürnberg stehen. Naja, so klingt das dann halt auch.
Hat natürlich irgendwie auch wieder einen Charme. Ich erinnere mich auch sehr gerne zum Beispiel an ein Interview, das sie hat mit Marcel Schäfer vom VfL Wolfsburg, übers Handy. Da hat er gerade seinem kleinen Sohn beim Kicken zugeguckt, irgendwie von der F- oder E-Jugend des VfL Wolfsburg. Und man hatte im Hintergrund immer diese entspannte Freizeit-Fußball- Atmosphäre. Immer mal wieder ein Schiedsrichter pfiff, aber nicht so viele, sehr F-Jugend. Immer mal wieder unterzaghaft reinrufen. Ploppen des Balls fand ich sehr schön. Führt jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen weit. Die Sofa-Quarterbacks kann ich noch empfehlen bei Sportradar 360. Wer sich für NFL interessiert, sehr hörenswert. So, wir waren aber eigentlich bei den Podcasts, die sich monothematisch einem Verein widmen, in der ersten Bundesliga. Da haben wir noch einige auf der Liste, was sehr erfreulich ist, auch wenn diese Liste immer noch nicht vollständig ist. Das heißt, jeder da draußen sollte sich herausgefordert fühlen, was eigenes zu starten. Tja, ich weiß gar nicht, zu welchem Podcast man da zuerst den Bogen schlagen sollte.
Fangen wir mit A an. Aufe Ohren. Ich glaube, die haben jetzt mittlerweile auch zweistellige Folgenzahlen, also gibt es nur nicht so ganz lange. Und ja, bespricht alles, was beim BVB wichtig ist. Vor allen Dingen natürlich das Sportliche, also es wird viel über Taktik, über Spieler, über den Trainer gesprochen. Da gab es natürlich in dieser Saison auch sehr viel Negatives zu besprechen, beziehungsweise man hat den auch immer so ein bisschen angehört, dass sie manchmal so ein bisschen ratlos waren, was ich sehr sympathisch fand. Und ja, es ist ein Fan-Talk aber auch, also es geht auch viel darum, zum Beispiel jetzt zum Pokalfinale in Berlin gab es dann halt auch Tipps drumrum, was man denn so in Berlin irgendwie machen könnte, wo man sich trifft und so. Wird halt auch über Fan-Themen gesprochen, was ich sehr, sehr angenehm finde, weil man da halt auch so ein bisschen was mit bekommt, was halt sonst nicht so in der Zeitung steht. Und ja, ich habe immer das Gefühl, die sind ganz gut so vorbereitet, was so den Ablauf der Sendung angeht. Und das macht es eigentlich sehr, sehr angenehm. Die kennen sich mittlerweile auch ganz gut, die Jungs, die das machen. Also aufe Ohren kann ich eigentlich jedem BVB-Fan auf jeden Fall ans Herz legen, aber auch denjenigen, die Lust haben, sich so ein bisschen an dem Verein zu reiben, weil die Herren auch mit ihrer Meinung gegenüber anderen Vereinen überhaupt nicht hinterm Berg halten, was manchmal ein bisschen anstrengend ist, aber manchmal auch sehr angenehm ist, je nachdem um welchen Verein es geht.
Soll ich dich jetzt fragen, bei welchem Verein du das angenehm findest?
Natürlich nicht.
Kommt aus dem schwarzgelb.de Umfeld, also sprich auch durchaus Fan-Team-Hintergrund und von daher eben das, was Klaas sagt, auch durchaus in Fan-Team sehr kompetent und ich finde, das macht es ja oft dann auch höhrenswert für Fans anderer Vereine, während das Sezieren der Fehlpässe eines gewissen Mittelfeldspielers bei anderen Vereinen mich dann auch eher weniger kickt. Und deswegen auf Ohren auch von mir unbedingt empfehlenswert.
Man könnte meinen, wir hätten diesen Ablauf so geplant, aber es ist tatsächlich jetzt spontan entstanden, denn ein Podcast, der sich zwar mit Fehlpässen beschäftigt, aber trotzdem auch für Vereine anderer Fans, nein, für Fans anderer Vereine hörenswert ist, ist der Fehlpass-Podcast, der eigentlich ein FC Bayern-Podcast ist von Jalcin Imri. Wir haben ihn vorhin schon genannt, einer der älteren Podcasts, die es so gibt. Immer wieder aber mit Gästen von anderen Vereinen, also oft ist zum Beispiel vom VfB Stuttgart die Ertösirü zu Gast. Hat auch ein sehr gutes Format zur WM gemacht, wie ich fand. Und unbedingt empfehlenswert, wie ich finde. Ich habe mein Herz an den FC Bayern verloren, deswegen fällt es mir natürlich besonders leicht, diesen Podcast zu hören. Ich habe allerdings auch mein Herz an den Yalcin verloren, der den Podcast moderiert und eine Stimme hat, die einen quasi in den Arm nimmt, während man den Podcast hört. Kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen. Und auch immer wieder mit Einblicken in die Fanszene, finde ich persönlich sehr empfehlenswert.
Das sehe ich genauso. Also ich bin kein Bayern-Fan und ich höre das trotzdem gerne. Vor allem natürlich diese WM-Nummer. Ich glaube, das war ja für ihn auch so ein Mammut-Projekt. Ich glaube, er hat ja auch jeden Tag fast gesendet.
Der fast tägliche WM-Podcast war ja der Untername der Sendung.
Und ich habe alle Folgen gehört. Fand ich wirklich sehr gut, weil er auch da große Potpourri an Gästen hatte irgendwie. Das war ganz angenehm, dass da immer wieder andere Leute waren und dann Yalcin mit seiner – du hast es schon gesagt – Stimme wie ein Glas Chanterie oder so. Wirklich sehr, sehr gut. Also er sendet ein bisschen zu selten, finde ich. Kann man mal kritisch anmerken.
Ja, absolut. Aber ich kenne da ein paar Hintergründe. Es wurde da equipmenttechnisch aufgerüstet und jetzt geht es ab, um das mal so zu sagen.
Freue mich drauf.
Was man da auch dazu sagen kann, zumindest ganz häufig, sitzen die ja wirklich auch in einem Raum. Und es wurde in letzter Zeit, glaube ich, ging es dann gar nicht mehr, dass Skype dazu geschaltet wurde. Anfangs war, glaube ich, das ab und zu mal der Fall. Und ich finde, davon profitiert so ein Podcast auch immens. Und das ist leider etwas, was bei dieser ganzen Mein-Sport-Radio-Geschichte oftmals so ein bisschen untergeht. Also da wird fast nur über Skype miteinander kommuniziert. Und ich finde, gerade wenn es um Vereine geht, wo Leute sich ja auch wirklich mit dem Herzen engagieren und wo Emotionen im Spiel sind, da muss man sich ja auch mal in die Augen gucken können. Also deswegen ist aus meiner Sicht mein Peerpass auch eine ganz große Stärke.
Wobei das natürlich auch ein Trade-Off ist. Also in der Schlusskonferenz zum Beispiel nehmen wir ja auch über Skype auf. Was ein Riesenproblem ist, weil man nicht nonverbal moderieren kann. Das heißt, manchmal sehen die Leute nicht, wie ich halt den Müll rausbringe, während sie… Nein, mache ich natürlich nicht. Ich höre immer aufmerksam zu. Aber geht halt manchmal nicht anders. Aber durchaus finde ich auch, dass das dem Podcast ganz besonders gut tut, dass man im Raum sitzt. So wie auch zum Beispiel bei Collinas Abend, merkt man das auch eindeutig. Aber ihr seid ja eh wie ein altes Ehepaar, Klaas, deswegen. Da passt eh alles. Natürlich. Ehen, die lange halten, sind immer zu loben. Vielleicht kann ich dann an der Stelle noch zwei andere Bayern-Podcasts nennen. Dann haben wir den Verein abgehandelt. Zum einen Mirsahn Roth vom gleichnamigen Blog, das mit einem sehr hohen Qualitätsanspruch über den FC Bayern berichtet. Die haben auch einen Podcast und ähnlich qualitativ hochwertig geht es in dem Podcast zur Sache. Sehr detailliert und auch durchaus mal mit einem Fokus auf spieltaktische Überlegungen, was ich immer ganz angenehm finde. Und als weiteres Format die Erfolgsfans, die ein bisschen unter ihrem Namen leiden. Den Namen haben sie sich damals gegeben. Ich glaube, das war in der Ära van Gaal, als die Erfolgsfans kritisiert wurden. Und noch heute werden sie aber von Bayern-Fans beschimpft. Sie seien ja nur Erfolgsfans. Etwas meinungsstarker, etwas breiter in den Themen. Da wird auch mal über potenzielle Transfers geredet. Haben jetzt ein sehr, sehr bemerkenswertes Projekt sich aufgeheizt, haben die Chronik des FC Bayern zum 25-jährigen Jubiläum im Deutschen Judischen Museum ausfindig gemacht und komplett eingescannt und via OCR durchsuchbar gemacht. In der Form liegt es meines Wissens nach nicht mal dem FC Bayern vor, zumindest in der Qualität. Und haben da jetzt eine eigene Seite zugemacht, wo man auch mitarbeiten kann, diese Chronik zu vervollständigen, Spielernamen auf Fotos herauszufinden. Total gutes Projekt, wie ich finde. Natürlich jetzt vor allem für FC Bayern-Fans interessant, aber ich mag das immer, wenn sich die Leidenschaft von Fans in mehr ausdrückt als eine Bratwurst zu kaufen, Bier und sich in die Kurve zu stellen, sondern sich richtig mit der Geschichte des Vereins auseinanderzusetzen. Finde ich immer sehr angenehm.
Auf jeden Fall. Was ich bei denen ganz witzig finde, wo du vorhin sagtest, wo man Podcasts hört, die haben erzählt, es gibt wohl einen Fanclub, die holen sich die Podcastfolge, laden sich die runter, brennen die auf CD und wenn die dann im Bus sitzen, um zum Spiel zu fahren, hören die sich alle zusammen diesen Podcast an.
Ja, stimmt. Das hat er mir auch schon erzählt. Da habe ich schon überlegt, ob ich mal an den ankommenen Fanbussen Rasenfunk-Aufkleber verteilen sollte.
Direkt die CD ist.
Ja, oder die CDs. So schnell produzieren wir leider nicht. Ja, aber sehr interessant. Ich glaube, die haben auch wahnsinnig viele Downloads, also quasi Leute, die sich über den Browser ihre Sendung anhören, wenn ich das nur richtig im Kopf habe. Wirklich interessant, wie man so unterschiedliche Zielgruppen anspricht.
Ich will bei dem Mirsanroth noch ganz kurz einhaken. Die haben gerade am Anfang sehr, sehr darauf geachtet, dass ihre Folgen nicht länger werden als eine Stunde. Ich habe dann immer insistiert und gesagt, das hat doch gar nichts damit zu tun, macht doch ruhig länger, wenn es das Thema hergibt. Und in den letzten Folgen sind sie immer schon so eine Viertelstunde drüber gewesen über der Stunde. Ich beobachte das mit sehr wohlwollendem Interesse und hoffe, sie gönnen sich da noch mehr.
Hast du es wieder geschafft. Das ist natürlich derjenige, der eine Stunde Berufsweg hat. Der treibt dann alle Podcasts dazu, dass sie länger werden. Aber ich finde grundsätzlich einfach, man soll sich so viel Zeit nehmen, wie man braucht. Ich meine, bei der Schlusskonferenz versuche ich auch, dass wir irgendwie nicht zu wahnsinnig über die 90 Minuten rausrauschen, aber auch so aus dem Gefühl heraus, dass ich immer habe, irgendwann nervt es auch immer, auf denselben Spieltag zu blicken. Aber grundsätzlich so viel Zeit nehmen, wie man braucht, finde ich auch. Viel Zeit nimmt sich ja auch der Podcast, würde ich sagen.
Genau, ich war jetzt ein bisschen beleidigt, nachdem wir mit Aufruhrohren angefangen haben mit A, dass wir jetzt nicht mit B gleich weitergemacht haben, aber passt schon. Ja, Podcast, der Podcast über den ersten FC Göln und ich vergesse, was das sonst noch alles behandelt, aber wird moderiert von Axel auf Twitter Lost in Nippes und ist inzwischen auch schon kurz vor der 50. Man lädt sich auch zu jeder Sendung immer Gäste ein. Das ist dann teilweise per Skype. Ich glaube, manchmal sitzen die auch zusammen, aber größtenteils sind sie per Skype. Und wie ich finde, sehr launig. Nun höre ich dieser kölschen Mundart generell sowieso sehr gerne zu. Deswegen spricht mich das auch nochmal besonders an. Und ich habe natürlich auch da so eine gewisse Beziehung zum FC. Ja, Hassliebe trifft es nicht ganz, aber dieser Verein polarisiert natürlich auch sehr. Und bei mir ist es nicht immer was Positives, was ich mit dem Verein verbinde. Und der Axel hat natürlich auch so eine Art dieses Kölner Selbstverständnis von eigentlich müssten wir Champions League nicht nur spielen, sondern auch jedes Jahr gewinnen, sehr charmant drüber zu bringen. Und das ist etwas, was ich beim Zuhören sehr, sehr schätze. Ich finde es ein bisschen schade, dass er dann tatsächlich von den Fan-Themen so ein bisschen entfernt ist, also von dem, was dann tatsächlich in der Kurve passiert. Da hat er dann in einer Sendung auch übelst auf die Fresse bekommen, weil er sich so ein bisschen abschätzig geäußert hat. Das war dann nachdem diese ganze Geschichte mit Kollektivstrafen in Köln so hochgehypt ist und der Block gesperrt wurde und hat dann daraus aber eine Schlussfolgerung gezogen, die ich bemerkenswert fand. Er hat sich nämlich für die nächste Sendung dann Leute eingeladen, die genau über dieses Thema gesprochen haben und hat also in aller Öffentlichkeit quasi sich an den Pranger gestellt oder das Büßerhemd angezogen und hat gesagt, in der nächsten Sendung repariere ich das jetzt. Das hat mir unheimlich viel Respekt abgenötigt. Ansonsten, wie gesagt, höre ich sehr gerne und beste Grüße nach Köln an der Stelle.
Ich bin auch großer Fan von dem Podcast. Auch wenn ich mit dem FC so meine Schwierigkeiten habe. Aber was Axel da so macht, ist halt immer sehr launig. Es ist immer unterhaltsam. Es gibt immer sehr unterhaltsame Momente, die auch manchmal gar nichts mit Fußball zu tun haben. Wie nennt er das, was er mit Enzo macht? Quick Cuts. Wo er jetzt mittlerweile versucht, den Spieltag vorher zu tippen. Ich glaube, das ist nicht für jeden was. Das muss man einfach mal ausprobieren, weil die beiden auch so eine Art haben, die vielleicht dem einen oder anderen sagt, so näher bereitet euch mal besser vor. Aber ich finde es sehr unterhaltsam. Ich höre das immer sehr, sehr gerne.
Ein bisschen der Phipps-Asmussen der Fußballpodcasts, wie ich finde. Sehr hohe Witzdichte, nicht jeder davon zündet.
Kann man jetzt nicht ganz so stehen lassen. Also ich finde schon, dass mehr Witze zünden als bei Phipps-Asmussen, also deutlich mehr.
Jetzt weiß ich nicht, wen von beiden du eigentlich gerade beleidigst. Ich halte einfach nur fest, du möchtest es sich nicht verscherzen. Das sei dir unbenommen, dann wollen wir das auch nicht. Ihr habt mich jetzt in ganz schöne Redouille gebracht wegen dieser blöden Wir fangen bei A an. Ich glaube auf der Liste, weil ich habe natürlich keine alphabetisch sortierte Liste, ich glaube, ihr müsst als nächstes dran sein mit dem Eintracht Frankfurt Podcast. Sehr empfehlenswert. Wir hatten in der Schlusskonferenz öfter Marvin zu Gast, den ich unfassbar mag und auch im Podcast sehr gerne höre, denn er hat eine Begeisterung, eine kindliche Begeisterung in der Stimme und gleichzeitig kann er sich über Stunden aufregen, über Kleinigkeiten. Das ist eine Kombination, die mir sehr gut gefällt. Die machen auch sehr, sehr regelmäßig Podcasts. Also sind jetzt schon bei Folge 184. Die gute Fe ist zurück, ist die letzte. Eintracht Frankfurt, monothematisch, aber auch sehr viel über den FSV Frankfurt. Immer wenn die entsprechenden Gäste zu Gast sind, was ich auch sehr... Also mir hat das viel über diesen Verein beigebracht, was ich vorher gar nicht wusste. Sehr empfehlenswert. Kann man wirklich gerne mal reinhören.
Vor allen Dingen, du hast Marvin erwähnt. Ich glaube, Maik, du hast ja über den Rasenfunk Royale geschrieben, dass er so einer wäre. Da wäre es auch unterhaltsam, wenn er das Telefonbuch vorlesen würde. Und das würde ich vollkommen unterstreichen. Manchmal sind seine Satzkonstruktionen so, dass man gar nicht mehr weiß, wie er da rauskommt. Aber er schafft es dann auch irgendwie immer wieder. Aber ich finde auch seine Gäste sehr gut. Ich finde es auch ganz gut, dass da mal ein paar Frauen sitzen. Also ich habe vorhin ja auch schon mal die Christel erwähnt. Aber es sind halt... Es sind oft irgendwie so Männerrunden, die da sitzen. Und da ist es dann irgendwie auch mal ganz schön, dass das da auch so ein bisschen Pari-Pari ist. Und Eintracht Frankfurt ist jetzt nicht mein allerliebster Verein, weil ich da auch so ein paar blöde Erfahrungen gemacht habe. Aber wenn man denen so zuhört, dann ist das dann alles nicht mehr so schlimm. Und es ist auch immer sehr, sehr hintergründig dann über die Eintracht. Also die beschäftigen sich, glaube ich, da schon sehr, sehr viel mit. Das macht auf jeden Fall sehr viel Spaß.
Das mit der Frauenquote ist sowieso ein wichtiger Punkt. Es gibt viel zu wenig weibliche Stimmen in der Podcastlandschaft generell und auch bei den Fußballpodcasts. Kleiner Gruß mal an die Edward-Piratin Mara Braun, Mainz 05-Fan. Ich glaube, die plant einen Mainz 05-Podcast und mit diesem Aufruf möchte ich jetzt auch sozialen Druck aufbauen, dass das dann auch umgesetzt wird.
Finde ich gut. Die konnte sehr gut reden im Rasenfunk Royale. Die war sehr, sehr schnell, aber sehr viel untergebracht dann auch. Das finde ich sehr gut. Soll ich sie mal machen.
Das wäre doch schön, wenn dieser Podcast zustande kommt. Was kommt nach E mit F haben wir nix? Grün-Weiß.
Grün-Weiß. Werder Bremen. Auch nicht mein Lieblingsverein, aber den Machern höre ich wirklich sehr, sehr gern zu, weil das ist, als ob Thomas Schaf einen Podcast erfinden würde. Sehr nüchtern, sehr ruhig, eine sehr angenehme Gesprächsatmosphäre. Die haben klare Meinungen, sind da auch nicht immer einer Meinung, wenn es um ihren Verein geht. Das finde ich auch immer ganz schön, wenn Leute aufeinandertreffen, die nicht immer einer Meinung sind, sondern sich auch ein bisschen aneinander reimen. Sprechen auch viel über Taktik. Das finde ich auch ganz gut, dass man da mal einen anderen Blick auf das Werder-Spiel bekommt, von Leuten, die jedes Spiel gucken. Kritisieren würde ich da, es gibt ein bisschen wenig über die Fanszene, habe ich das Gefühl, aber sehr viel Fußball und den grün-weiß Stammtisch, da würde ich das Stammtisch fast rausstreichen wollen, weil das hat überhaupt nichts mit irgendwelchen Sonntagmorgensendungen bei Spatenkanälen zu tun, sondern das ist wirklich ein sehr guter Werder Bremen-Podcast.
Auf jeden Fall, ja. Ich finde das sehr gut, wie du jeden Podcast anfängst mit, ist nicht mal Lieblingsverein, aber...
Ja, war er recht.
Ja, ja, natürlich, natürlich. Wir haben, wenn wir bei Geese noch einen Podcast, der erst eine Nullnummer produziert hat, den hast du in letzter Sekunde noch entdeckt, Klaas. Wie bist du überhaupt darauf aufmerksam geworden?
Irgend ein Tweet. Durch Zufall.
Verrückt. Möchtest du uns noch sagen, was für ein Podcast das ist?
Es ist ein Schalke 04 Podcast, aber du hast mich jetzt so kalt erwischt, dass ich nicht weiß, wie er heißt.
Ich glaube, er heißt Glück auf Podcast. Eventuell sogar noch Glück auf Pils. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber Glück auf, da bin ich mir sehr sicher, weil ich habe mich schon gesucht und nicht gefunden in meinem Podcatcher. Ich brauche den Halsess.
Irgendetwas mit Bier auf jeden Fall. Die haben ein sehr schönes Intro produziert, was jetzt schon auf der Seite steht. Und ja, die kommen ja wahrscheinlich in deine Podroll und dann kann man da ja mal reinhören. Schalke, die hatten früher mal so ein, es gab so ein Hangcast, heißt das glaube ich, wenn man das bei Google macht. Der hieß glaube ich 19.04. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es die noch gibt, ehrlich gesagt. Von daher Schalke, da ist noch Platz. Die sollen auf jeden Fall mal loslegen.
Genau, ich habe jetzt natürlich schnell mal nachgeguckt. Glück auf minus Pils.de und es nennt sich Glück auf Pils.de der Schalke Podcast. Bald in deinem Ohr. Vermutlich eher eine Drohung.
Und die URL tatsächlich mit Ü geschrieben, ne?
Diese Schalke. Absolut verrückt. Ich habe komplett den Überblick übers Alphabet verloren, aber wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, sind wir beim Leverkusen-Pod angereicht. Ein Bayer 04 Leverkusen-Podcast.
Und das ist, glaube ich, mit das verrückteste Projekt, was es gibt. Bayer Leverkusen ist nicht mein Verein. Entschuldigung, ich lasse das ab sofort. Aber das ist ein Podcast, gibt es auch schon über 100 Folgen von, irgendwie so zwischen, ich glaube so 30 Minuten und einer Stunde. Und die Jungs und Mädels, die sitzen in aller Welt. Eric sitzt, glaube ich, in Los Angeles, Patrick in Singapur und Tom und Frieda in Bonn sind auch nicht immer dieselben Leute dabei. Die laden sich auch immer noch Gäste ein. Also zum Beispiel war der Kicker-Redakteur Frank Lusse mal da oder Stefan Klüttermann von der Rheinischen Post war da oder auch Alex, mit dem ich Collinas Erben mache, also Alex Feuerheit war da, weil der hat ja mal eine Leverkusen-Chronik geschrieben. Und ja, Hauptgesprächsthema ist dann halt bei Leverkusen, manchmal aber auch der Verein, gegen den dann als nächstes gespielt wird. Da gibt es dann auch oft Gäste dazu und es ist sehr spielbezogen. Diskutieren halt auch viel über Taktik, wenig über die Fanszene, mehr dann auch über einzelne Spieler, was die vielleicht besser oder schlechter machen als andere. Bier ist auch immer wichtig, wird dann gern drüber gesprochen, welches Bier denn da gerade getrunken wird. Und was man halt beim Leverkusen-Pod noch dazu sagen muss, er ist auf Englisch. Also das haben wir vorhin noch vergessen. Es ist noch ein englischsprachiger Podcast, den wir noch dabei haben. Und das über Bayer Leverkusen.
Völlig verrückt. Das ist wirklich absolut verrückt. Fast verrückter wäre eigentlich nur ein deutschsprachiger Podcast über Bayer. Nur für Leverkusen finde ich.
Vielleicht findet sich da ja noch wer. Mal gucken.
Und dann habe ich hier noch auf meiner Liste stehen, das Rautenradio.
Also das nicht mein Verein. Nichtsdestotrotz leider ein ganz trauriges Thema. Ich habe nämlich in der Vorbereitung gesagt, ich treffe mich ja samstags mit dem Sven und dann spreche ich mal an, wie es denn da eigentlich aussieht. Tatsächlich ist, wenn das Textil vergehend das inhaltliche Vorbild des Middantons war und ist, so ist das Rautenradio der technische Geburtshelfer gewesen, weil ohne Sven, aka Herzi, auf Twitter hätte es den Middanton definitiv nicht gegeben. Und er hat uns gerade am Anfang mit der Technik unheimlich viel geholfen und ist auch heute noch Mitrat und hat zur Seite, wenn mal irgendwas hakt. Ja, also das Rautenradio ist ein Produkt von eben besagten Sven zusammen mit Florian aka Ned Fuller auf Twitter, die über den HSV sehr regelmäßig zusammengesessen haben und das dann eben vertont haben. Und leider spreche ich in der Vergangenheitsform, weil durch den Weggang von Florian von diesem Verein beziehungsweise der AG hin zu anderen Möglichkeiten, sich im Fußball zu amüsieren, ist auch das Rautenradio jetzt beendet. Also Sven hat mir das vorhin telefonisch noch mal bestätigt, schließt nicht aus, dass sich das irgendwie in naher Zukunft noch mal in anderer Zusammensetzung neu bildet, da vielleicht auch unter einem neuen Namen. Aber bis dahin war es halt immer sehr, sehr höhrenswert für St. Pauli-Fans, insbesondere nach HSV-Niederlagen, was ja doch sehr häufig der Fall war, weil Florian eine sehr sympathische Art hat, sich aufzuregen und Sven eine umso schönere, ihn eiskalt auflaufen zu lassen. Und das hat sich auch immer in diesem Tandem sehr, sehr gut ergänzt und hat auch davon sehr profitiert, dass die beiden eben in einer Wohnung immer zusammen saßen. Und ja, habe ich also sehr gerne gehört, war mir oftmals auch zu fußballlastig. Also da wurde dann das zwölfte Mal erzählt, dass Jansen den Ball ja hätte er laufen können, wenn er denn laufen würde und dass der Fehlpass nicht passieren darf und so weiter und so fort. Hatte dann aber eben seine Stärken in den Momenten, wo die beiden so ein bisschen sich dann eben teilweise aufgeregt haben oder gegenseitig gekitzelt haben und wurde zum Ende hin auch mehr Fan-Themen lastiger, aber wie gesagt, das ist leider jetzt eben Geschichte.
Das ist wirklich sehr sehr schade. Das ist mit einer der Podcasts auch von denen, ich eigentlich jede Folge gehört habe. Vor allem auch, wie du sagst, diese Kombination der etwas stoischen gegen den sehr aufgeregten. Ich hoffe einfach mal, dass die das irgendwie wieder hinbekommen, da weiterzumachen und der Florian, der sagt zwar immer, dass ihn der HSV nicht mehr interessiert, stimmt natürlich nicht, dann soll er halt nicht mehr jede Folge da sein, sondern ab und zu mal. Ich möchte, dass hier auch sozialer Druck jetzt aufgebaut wird. Alle, die das hören, sollen die beiden mal ein bisschen beackern, dass da weitergemacht wird. Ich vermisse das Rautenradio.
Ja, definitiv. Rautenradiodoufés ist das Hashtag, unter dem ihr die Tweets absenden könnt und jetzt baut man ein bisschen Druck auf. Aber durchaus bemerkenswert, ich wusste gar nicht, dass der Herzi auch bei Milan Ton so viel geholfen hat. Ich wusste nur, dass er auch bei Manns-Sportradio.de viel geholfen hat. Die Hebamme deutscher Fußballpodcasts möchte man fast sagen.
Ich glaube, er saß sogar bei euren ersten Podcasts noch dabei, oder?
Ja, also die allererste Sendung saß er dabei und musste dann immer aus der Entfernung mal Hallo rufen, weil irgendjemand ihn genötigt hat, rein zu sprechen, weil er einfach die Technik aufgebaut hat und zur Verfügung gestellt hat. Inzwischen sind wir da zum Glück autark und müssen ihn da nicht mehr ständig belatschen. Aber bei den ersten Sendungen war es auch dann so, dass ich immer am Tag vor der Sendung oder am Tag der Sendung hingefahren bin, von ihm ein, zwei Headsets geholt hab und die ihm am nächsten Tag dann wieder zurückgebracht hab. Also wie gesagt, Herzi, ich glaube auch bei Collinas Erben ja durchaus mit der Hardware hilfreich gewesen und so. Und da wahrscheinlich wirklich bei vielen Podcasts irgendwie im Hintergrund beteiligt. Und von daher bin ich auch guter Dinge, dass sich da irgendwas Neues ergeben wird.
Ja, es wird sicherlich ein HSV-Film finden lassen, der sich aufregt. Denen sperrt man doch mit in einem Raum alles. Fertig, fertig, siehlaube. Zur Not setze ich mich dahin.
Ich glaube, es wird schwierig, einen HSV-Fan zu finden, der sich aktuell nicht aufregt.
Ja, oder Klaas, bist du nicht HSV-Fan? Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen. Was ist dein Verein?
Ja, ich bin aber Fan vom großen HSV.
HSV-Hande Witt. Von einer Raute zur anderen. Wir haben noch Vollraute, einen sehr empfehlenswerten Podcast.
Genau. Vollraute beschäftigt sich mit Borussia Mönchengladbach. Die gibt es jetzt auch schon seit weit über 50 Folgen und die sind immer besser geworden. Unter dem Leitspruch, nie neutral, immer durch die Vereinsbrille besprechen die halt die Spiele von der Borussia. Ist eigentlich auch immer so die dieselbe Combo, die da sitzt, auch schon seit ziemlich langer Zeit. Also nicht immer exakt dieselben, aber die sind auch schon ganz gut aufeinander eingespielt. Die wissen, wie man sich sozusagen in einem Podcast verhalten muss, wenn man über Skype zueinander geschaltet ist. Also eine sehr gute Gesprächsatmosphäre auch in dem Team irgendwie. Die haben auch zwischendurch eine ganz schöne Sache mit dem Bobcast irgendwie gemacht. Ich glaube, da haben sie dann vor dem Spiel bei dem einen die Folge gemacht und nach dem Spiel bei dem anderen die Folge veröffentlicht. Also auch so ein bisschen über die Vereinsgrenzen, gerade zwischen Gladbach und Köln, ist das ja bemerkenswert. Also über die Vereinsgrenzen hinaus zu arbeiten. Ja, und was ganz lustig ist, ich glaube man wartet immer noch auf Folge 50. Die haben sie einfach ausgelassen in der zählweise. Haben sich gesagt, nee da wollen wir mal alle zusammenkommen und die dann feiern. Also Folge 50, vielleicht kriegen sie es ja in der Sommerpause jetzt hin. Also wer sich über die über die Borussia informieren will auf Deutsch, hört Vollraute oder er hört Vollraute Abroad. Das ist jetzt das englischsprachige Pendant sozusagen. Einer der Macher, jetzt lass mich lügen, wie heißt er? Manuel glaube ich. Genau, der sitzt in Schottland, also wohnt dort und hat jetzt neu im Angebot einen englischsprachigen Borussia München Gladbach Podcast. Vielleicht ja auch ein Weg für alle anderen, um jetzt auch in aller Welt dann demnächst gehört zu werden. Gerade so ein Bayern München Podcast, nur auf Englisch. Ich glaube, das wird auch weltweit gehört werden. Oder, Max?
Vermutlich schon. Mir ist es tatsächlich jetzt passiert, ich bin mal zu Reddit gegangen und habe da den Rasenfunk beworben, weil ich mal gucken wollte, was da so rüberkommt an neuen Hörern. Da war das tatsächlich die erste Frage im allgemeinen Bundesligaforum, dass sehr englischsprachig geprägt ist, welche englischsprachigen Podcasts. Ich den kennen würde. Also wer sich des Englischen mächtig fühlt und einen Podcast machen will, der hat auf jeden Fall viele Hörer. Das würde ich auch so sagen. Und in den USA sind Podcasts ja nochmal zum Beispiel ganz anders durchgesetzt als hier. Jetzt haben wir schon ganz viele Bundesliga-Vereine genannt an Podcasts und trotzdem noch lange nicht alle. Das ist wirklich sehr schade. Hier mit der Aufruf, macht gerne einen eigenen Podcast oder animiert irgendjemanden, den ihr dazu fähig haltet. Wir werden am Ende der Sendung auch nochmal kurz drüber sprechen, was so die Anlaufstellen sein können, wenn man einen Podcast startet. Jetzt mal ausgenommen, dass man uns direkt bei Twitter anschreibt. Ich denke, habe ich jetzt nicht mit euch abgesprochen, aber das ist dann eigentlich auch okay, uns auch zu fragen um Rat. Grundsätzlich wisst ihr ja, dass der Herzi eigentlich die erste Adresse sein sollte. Der macht das ja anscheinend auch gerne und hauptberufmäßig, dass er neue Podcasts aus der Wiege hebt.
Ne, da kann man vielleicht auch nochmal zu anmerken, dass es wirklich so bei allen Podcastern, die ich bisher angesprochen habe, die Hilfsbereitschaft war immer sehr groß. Also auch wenn es zum Beispiel darum ging, man hat Probleme mit Blog oder Probleme mit irgendwelchen Audiodateien oder Aufnahmesituationen. Du kannst eigentlich jeden fragen, es gibt eigentlich keinen, der sagt, ne, dir helfe ich nicht, sondern selbst die bekanntesten Podcaster in Deutschland, also hier Tim Pritloff und Co. die helfen immer. Vielleicht können wir es auch an dieser Stelle einfach einbauen, wer ein Podcast machen will. Es ist ja gar nicht so schwierig mehr. Man kann mittlerweile – mit dem iPhone kann man sehr gut Podcasts aufnehmen, habe ich mittlerweile gelernt. Man kann auch ganz einfache Mikrofone kaufen. Es gibt zum Beispiel den Lautsprecher als Podcastempfehlung für jeden, der ein Podcast anfangen möchte, weil da wird einfach so Schritt für Schritt erklärt, wie man ganz einfach Podcasts erstellen kann und online stellen kann und was für Probleme es gibt bei Aufnahmesituationen, was es zu beachten gibt, was man verbessern kann und so weiter und so fort. Und wenn man dann noch mehr Bock drauf hat, dann meldet man sich einfach bei sendegate.de an. Das ist jetzt das neue Podcaster-Forum, wo sich alle Podcaster aus allen Abteilungen treffen und über Podcasts diskutieren und auch bei allen Fragen nachhelfen. Also, wer Podcasts machen will, einfach tun. So schwer ist es gar nicht mehr.
Definitiv, ja. Und ergänzend dazu noch gibt es einen YouTube-Podcast, auch YouTube-only. Das ist auch mein größter Kritikpunkt an diesem Projekt. Die Podcast-Piloten sind jetzt, glaube ich, bei Episode 5 angelangt, die auch sich monothematisch in jeder Sendung mit den einzelnen Schritten beschäftigen, die man so vor sich hat, wenn man einen Podcast machen möchte. Also da geht es sowohl um Audio-Equipment als auch um die Frage, wie schiebe ich meinen Podcast zu iTunes, was muss ich dabei beachten und so weiter. Auch selbst empfehlen die Podcast-Piloten. Wir waren aber noch nicht ganz fertig mit der ersten Liga. Einen habe ich noch vergessen, ein bisschen ein Sonderfall. Fängt schon damit an, dass ich gar nicht sagen kann, ob ich ihn unter Z einsortieren sollte oder unter E. Es ist nämlich der Podcast Einlaufkinder vom Blog zum Blonden Engel bzw. von Frédéric Balin, der diesen Blog betreibt, zusammen mit einem Gesprächspartner. Ist auch ein bisschen thematisch schwierig zuzuordnen. Sehr unregelmäßige Veröffentlichungszeiträume. Definitiv zu empfehlen, immer zu turnieren. Also immer wenn es um die deutsche Nationalmannschaft und die französische gehen kann, dann sollte man mal gucken, ob die Einlaufkinder was produziert haben. Wenn sie aber auch mal über die Bundesliga reden, dann viel aus über den Hertha BSC. Und da es da ansonsten keinen Podcast gibt, zumindest keinen, der mir jetzt spontan einfiele, wollte ich das hier genannt haben. Einlaufkinder von Zum Blonden Engel. Ich glaube, man muss nach beiden suchen, um es zu finden. Sehr empfehlenswert und besonders bei Großereignissen definitiv hörendswert.
Was ich da ganz schön finde, dass die auch mal mit diesem, also wir haben jetzt immer darüber gesprochen, man trifft sich und podcastet oder man macht Skype und podcastet. Die haben sich auch einfach in eine Kneipe gesetzt. Man hört dann zwischendurch, wie die Bedienung ankommt und noch mal Bier bringt und das ist natürlich eine ganz andere Gesprächsatmosphäre. Und das finde ich eigentlich auch ganz gut. Man kann sich in Podcasts manchmal vielleicht ein bisschen mehr trauen mal zwischendurch und dann einfach mal sich in der Kneipe treffen und einfach mal podcasten. Also von daher ist was ganz anderes auch irgendwie dieser Podcast als alle anderen.
Definitiv. Es wird auch immer kommentiert, was jetzt gerade in der Kneipen-Playlist läuft. Und wenn sie mal nicht in der Kneipe sitzen, dann suchen sie nach adäquater Hintergrundbeschallung. Ich kann mich an eine Folge erinnern, da lief im Hintergrund dann schon das Champions League Spiel oder Länderspiel und sie haben noch drüber geredet. Sehr angenehm auch von der ganzen Atmosphäre her. Damit haben wir viele Empfehlungen ausgesprochen zu Erstliga-Podcasts. Noch mal ganz kurz der Hinweis. Ich mache das jetzt einfach alle zwei Stunden. Kurze Service-Durchsage. Wir erheben hier keinen Anspruch auf Vollständigkeit. Den erhebe ich so ein bisschen bei rasenfunk.de slash podroll. Was wir aber hier machen ist, wir reden jetzt einfach über die Podcasts, die wir auch hören und die wir dann tatsächlich auch empfehlen können. Das ist aber keine Wertung. Es darf sich hier niemand ausgeschlossen fühlen. Aber es wäre auch unrealistisch, wenn wir einfach 40 Podcasts hier empfehlen. So viel Zeit haben wir dann doch nicht und so viele Ohren haben wir gar nicht. Um das alles zu hören. Wir haben über die erste Liga geredet. Leider sieht es in der zweiten Liga nicht ganz so gut aus, was man die Podcastlandschaft angeht. Daher kommt vielleicht auch so ein bisschen die Forderung, dass wir im Rasenfunk mehr zweite Liga machen. Da sage ich mal ganz ehrlich, macht es doch selbst. Jetzt mal ganz im Ernst. Aber wir haben einen Podcast, der so ein bisschen über allen anderen thront allein, weil er in dieser Folge schon von uns allen genannt wurde. Ich glaube, er hat auch uns alle zum Thema Podcast gebracht, nämlich das Textilvergehen.
Wie schon mehrfach erwähnt, war das der, mit dem ich begonnen habe und der auch tatsächlich inhaltlich immer noch meiner Idealvorstellung, wie ich gerne den Millan-Ton machen würde, sehr nahe kommt bzw. besser ist, als der Millan-Ton es je kann, nämlich das Textilvergehen. Es sieht so aus, dass sich tatsächlich wöchentlich in einer Berliner Küche, zumindest stelle ich mir das so urig vor, vier bis fünf Personen treffen, um über das zurückliegende Spiel des ersten FC-Union Berlin zu sprechen. Sebastian führt diese oftmals entgleitende Diskussion. Ich sehe ihn immer haareraufend vor mir sitzen, wie er versucht, die Leute wieder ein bisschen einzufangen und wieder zum Thema zurückzulenken, was ihm manchmal besser, manchmal schlechter gelingt. Nichtsdestotrotz, ob man Union mag oder nicht, eine sehr launige Runde, die eben auch ihre Stärke daraus bezieht, dass zwar immer über das Spiel gesprochen wird und auch wöchentlich über das Spiel gesprochen wird, aber eben auch sehr viel über das Drumherum, was es natürlich bei Vereinen wie Union auch immer gibt. Stephanie ist noch da, Rudelbildung, der Gero ist oftmals dabei, Hans-Martin ist oftmals dabei, Robert ist oftmals dabei. Trotzdem immer wechselnde Besetzungen auch und ja, also kann man sich wirklich sehr gut anhören, unabhängig davon, ob man den 1. FC Union Berlin nun mag oder nicht, weil es einfach eine sehr launige Unterhaltung ist, die tatsächlich Spaß macht beim Zuhören.
Sie sprechen ja auch nicht nur über Union, sondern auch über Fan-Themen, die vielleicht vereinsübergreifend sind. Das finde ich auch immer ganz gut. Und die sitzen halt auch zusammen in der Küche, haben gutes Equipment und ich gucke eigentlich gar keine Spiele vor der Union Berlin und fühle mich da trotzdem immer sehr wohl dann in dieser Küchensituation. Ich durfte ja auch einmal dabei sein und Sebastian schlägt sich wirklich die Hand auf den Kopf und schüttelt so. Es ist fantastisch. Gero, der so ein bisschen ja das verrückte Moment da reinbringt und Sebastian, der versucht es zu ordnen. Dann haben sie, jeder hat so seine Position irgendwie auch in diesem Team. Und es ist wirklich, es ist immer noch, glaube ich, mit meinem Lieblings-Fußball-Podcast.
Es ist wirklich auch so ein bisschen so die Fußball-Podcast-Familie, die sich einmal wöchentlich zusammenfindet. Und dann hat man halt den Vater, das ist der Sebastian, der versucht das Ganze zu ordnen und dann die unterschiedlich ausgeprägten Kinder und die Mami, die eigentlich viel zu selten das Wort erhebt, weil immer wenn sie was sagt, ist es interessant. Oder halt genau, tatsächlich muss ich um die Kinder kümmern. Und der Podcast ist auch genauso, wie er sich anhört. Also ich habe auch das Textilvergehen als einen der ersten Podcasts gehört. Ich glaube, es war sogar auch derjenige, der mich zum Thema Podcast gebracht hat. Und ich habe mir das immer so vorgestellt, dass es so in der Berliner Küche stattfindet. Und dann war ich dort mal zu Besuch und es stimmt eins zu eins. Also man wird quasi dorthin eingeladen. Eine Reise für die Uhren. Sehr empfehlenswert. Und unheimlich professionell produziert alles.
Und Sebastian ist auch, das kann ich an dieser Stelle vielleicht auch mal sagen, einer, der es überhaupt möglich macht, dass es Collinas Erben in der Form gibt. Also sozusagen die zweite Hebamme von Podcasts.
Absolut. Ed Saumselig sollte man folgen und auch so unglaublich hilfsbereit. Und ich erinnere mich noch, ich war mal bei Ihnen eingeladen, kam während eines Union-Spiels, was mir schon furchtbar unangenehm war. Also weil mich nervt, dass wenn ich während eines Bayern-Spiels an die Tür gehen muss, da bin ich erstmal schlecht drauf. Und ich kam in dieses Wohnzimmer und dann saß da Tim Pritloff, deutscher Podcast Papst, gebeugt über ein riesiges Mischpult mit 500.000 Anschlüssen und hatte sich entschieden, weil das Spiel so schlecht ist, er verbessert jetzt mal das Setup vom Sebastian. Und dann durfte ich daneben sitzen, wie zweieinhalb Stunden über Kompressoren, Kalibrierungen und so weiter geredet wurde. Ich habe nichts verstanden, aber es war sehr, sehr interessant. Es war wirklich zeitlos. Tim hat wahrscheinlich nicht mal gemerkt, dass ich im Raum war. Er war so gefesselt von diesem riesigen Mischpult. So ungefähr war es ja. Als wir dann die einzelnen Sprecher simuliert haben und er dann quasi das Audio-Setup vorgenommen hat, da war ich dann wichtig. Ich durfte dann Steffi sein. Ok, jetzt führt es zu weit.
Nein, Steffis wunderbaren Dialekt, den ich jetzt einfach mal kann man nicht nachmachen. Und wenn ich den Podcast gehört habe und Steffi war dabei, dann bin ich immer kurz davor selber irgendwie zu versuchen, das nachzumachen. Das ist immer ganz peinlich. Aber es ist wirklich wunderschön, ihr zuzuhören.
Und es ist auch thematisch interessant, auch jetzt gerade nicht nur für Leute wie uns, die das Text tiefer gehen, schon sehr lange hören, sondern auch aktuell, weil ich glaube, dass der 1. Union Berlin ganz ähnliche Probleme durchmacht, die man unter anderem auch bei Borussia St. Pauli – Mist, jetzt habe ich ja das Sankt gesagt, das war sehr falsch – entdecken kann. Ich weiß nicht, ob du mir da zustimmst, Maik. Hinsichtlich Kultverein, jetzt in Anführungszeichen, und trotzdem sportliche Perspektive und so weiter.
Ja, völlig. Und wir sind dieser Modeerscheinung, Kultverein vielleicht schon ein paar Jahre in Entwicklung voraus und haben jetzt schon ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung sammeln können. Und das stimmt, aber genau, was du sagst, in den letzten Sendungen kam das ja immer mal wieder. Und ja, das lässt mich immer beim U-Bahn fahren dann meistens zwar laut auflachen, aber wir machen manchen Themen auch einfach nur dann vehement nicken.
Und damit kommen wir eigentlich zur zweiten großen Koryphäe der Zweitliga-Podcast. Es dreht sich über Pauli United, der Millern-Ton.
Der Millern-Ton. Es ist ein Fashion- und Beauty-Podcast mit einer Vorliebe für braune Wäsche. Hat ein Moderator, der versucht, den Laden irgendwie zusammenzuhalten, was aber immer nur mehr und oft auch weniger gelingt. Und das macht das Ganze auch irgendwie so sympathisch. Und es gibt auch gewisse Ähnlichkeiten zu diesem Textilvergehen, was ich glaube, hängt auch damit zusammen, dass der Moderator halt auch einen großen Faible für das Textilvergehen hat. Aber das ist nur eine Vermutung. Im Millern-Ton werden dann immer die letzten Spiele besprochen, das aber zum Glück auch immer relativ kurz, weil ich glaube, Spiele von St. Pauli will auch eigentlich keiner so richtig besprechen, habe ich das Gefühl. Und dann geht es halt so auch um das Vereinsbefinden allgemein. Also wenn wie in dieser Saison ab und zu mal der Trainer und der Sportdirektor gewechselt werden, dann wird das auch entsprechend kommentiert, was sehr angenehm ist. Und Vereinsbefinden trifft es dann, finde ich, auch noch ganz gut, weil es geht auch um das allgemeine Befinden des Vereins. Also da geht es um Fentoniere, um Choreos, um Ausstellungen, um Lesungen, um ja irgendwie 25-Jahres-Feste. Ich glaube, es war vom Fan-Haus oder so über die Jahreshauptversammlung. Also wirklich sehr breite Spektrum, was halt um diesen Verein herum passiert, was ich halt sehr, sehr genieße, weil wir haben es jetzt schon mehrfach gesagt, man kriegt davon ja sonst so wenig mit und das bekommen sie halt in ihrer Runde auch sehr, sehr angenehm hin, hocken da in irgendwie sehr angenehmen Sesseln, trinken ihr Bier dazu und kommen dann manchmal auch so vom Hölzchen aufs Stöckchen und ich sitze teilweise auch in der Bahn und lache ziemlich laut über die Formulierung, die da getroffen werden, die Themen, wie sie miteinander verknüpft werden und ja, es ist dann natürlich auch immer sehr schön, wenn sie dann irgendwie Gäste haben, also zum Beispiel, an wen erinnere ich mich? Thomas Meckle war da, weit bevor er dann Trainer und später dann Manager wurde, aber auch Spieler wie Jan-Philipp Kaller oder Sebastian Schachten waren zu Gast, Spieler, die mir jetzt gar nicht so viel gesagt haben, aber die natürlich für St. Pauli-Fans vor allen Dingen natürlich besonderes Interesse wahrscheinlich haben, die sich da auch eigentlich immer sehr sympathisch gezeigt haben. Vor allen Dingen natürlich Fabian Boll, seine Schiedsrichter-Geschichte. Ich werde sie jetzt nicht erzählen, weil er kann es viel besser als ich. Also, hört euch die Folge mit Fabian Boll auf jeden Fall nochmal von Melaton an. Sehr, sehr gut. Und auch die Folge mit Markus Wiebusch würde ich empfehlen. Der hat ja diesen wunderbaren Song, der Tag wird kommen machen über, ja, da geht es um Homophobie im Fußball. Das Lied bespricht einen Spieler, der irgendwann mal kommen wird, der sich als schwuler Fußballer outet. Auch vielleicht zur aktiven Karrierezeit und das ist dann hoffentlich ja kein Problem. Und Markus Wiebusch, der hat dann in seinem Interview auch da selber seine Hintergedanken gesprochen. Das war wirklich auch sehr, sehr hörenswert, sollte jeder hören. Und was bei Melaton auch sehr, sehr schön ist, ist dieses vor dem Spiel nach dem Spiel. Also, man lädt sich vor dem Spiel gegen Darmstadt jemanden ein, der über Darmstadt aus Darmstädter Perspektive sprechen kann und bespricht dann nach dem Spiel mit demselben oder mit einem anderen auch nochmal das Spiel, was, glaube ich, für die Leute, die diese Spiele dann auch vollständig gucken, einen sehr, sehr hohen Mehrwert hat. Von daher, dem Melaton, ich glaube, er sollte in keinem Podcast-Catcher dann irgendwie fehlen in Zukunft.
Dem stimme ich vollumfänglich zu und möchte noch hinzufügen, dass es einer der schönsten Podcastnamen ist, meiner Meinung nach.
Vielen Dank an beide. Zu dem Namen noch mal vielleicht ganz kurz, den hat tatsächlich unser Quotenpunker, hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt, also Tommy Molotov, dem eine oder anderen vielleicht auch aus einer Werbwirt-Millionär-Sendung noch bekannt erfunden, der gehörte der Kompen Podcast, gar nicht so richtig viel mit dem Begriff anfangen konnte, aber er sagt, der kann ja nur Melaton heißen. Das haben wir dann auch so übernommen. Und ansonsten glaube ich, von dem erwähnten Podcast heute, es ist der, der sich tatsächlich am wenigsten mit Fußball an sich beschäftigt, aber das ist auch okay.
Finde ich auch. Und vor allen Dingen, wer Wilko noch nicht kennt, sollte Wilko kennenlernen, oder?
Ja, und oft hinter Folgen unter wirklichen Dingen.
Weiß ich nicht. Wollte nicht zu sehr loben. Nein, also es ist wirklich eine schöne Runde. Am Anfang hatte ich ein bisschen Probleme, die Leute auseinanderzuhalten, aber mittlerweile jeder Einzelne ist in seiner Art da. Es wird auch immer schön geflaxt. Jeder wird irgendwie auch mal an Karren gepinkelt. Es ist wirklich sehr, sehr schön und macht sehr viel Spaß, zuzuhören.
Ach ja, dieses Leute auseinanderzuhalten, da muss ich mal kurz nochmal fragen. Hattet ihr das auch schon mal in einem Podcast von euch? Nee, ihr sitzt ja immer vor Ort, dass ihr die Leute nicht auseinanderhalten konntet. Ist euch noch nie passiert?
Während der Produktion?
Nein, also das ist bei uns halt der Vorteil. Wir treffen uns ja in den Fanräumen. Der FC St. Pauli ist ja, glaube ich, da einer der wenigen Vereine, der so etwas hat, wo sich also Fans tatsächlich Räumlichkeiten im Stadion gekauft haben als Gemeinschaft. Und da ist eben ein großer Konferenzraum auch. Und in dem treffen wir uns dann eben alle drei Wochen. Und von daher sehe ich tatsächlich meine Gegenüber. Und ich versuche trotzdem immer den Namen zu sagen, aber mir wird immer wieder auch genannt, das müsste ich häufiger machen.
Mache ich auch furchtbar schlecht in der Schlusskonferenz. Und ich hatte tatsächlich eine Aufnahme, ich sage jetzt nicht welche, bei der ich einen der Gesprächspartner bis dahin noch nie gehört hat. Den kannte ich nur von Twitter her und den anderen erst einmal. Und das war irgendwie, ich glaube, in einer ganz frühen Schlusskonferenz, die ich schon verdrängt hatte aufgrund schlechter Moderationsfähigkeit. Und da war es tatsächlich so, dass ich mir gedacht habe, meine Güte, die kann man ja überhaupt nicht unterscheiden. Ich müsste die jetzt anmoderieren. Aber ich wusste dann gar nicht mehr, wer jetzt gerade spricht und wem ich dann die nächste Frage zuweise. War mir ultra unangenehm.
Das ist dann der Vorteil, wenn man zusammen in einem Raum sitzt.
Definitiv.
Kann man mal hinzeigen. Du da, sag mal was.
Ja, vor allem meistens kennt man ja dann doch die Leute, mit denen man da in einem Raum sitzt. Vielleicht ist der Millern-Ton auch der Punkt, an dem wir am besten mal darüber reden können, wie eigentlich die Fußballvereine selbst auf Podcasts reagieren. Denn meines Wissens nach ist der – mir fällt gerade keine – Tottenham-Pauly der einzige Verein, der richtig aktiv den Podcast fördert. Sehe ich das richtig, Mike?
Richtig, ja. Wir können uns da wirklich gar nicht beklagen, sowohl was eben die Gäste anbelangt – also ich habe einen recht guten Draht – sicherlich auch aufgrund der Historie, dass es das Fan-Magazin Übersteiger jetzt schon über 20 Jahre gibt, zum Verein an sich, auch zu unserem Pressesprecher und dementsprechend – sage ich halt Bescheid – wir würden ganz gern dann demnächst bei der Sendung den und den Spieler haben. Das klappt dann auch und tatsächlich ist es so, dass wir als Verein eine Abteilung haben, die da heißt AFM – Abteilung fördernde Mitglieder, was bei anderen Vereinen Supporters oder ähnliches bedeutet und die hat sich auch als einen Abteilungszweck Förderung von Kultur im Fußballbereich auf die Fahnen geschrieben und hat unter diesem Mantel eben das AFM Radio gegründet. Das hat begonnen mit der ganz normalen – normal ist schon Quatsch – also mit der Berichterstattung oder Spielbeschreibung für Sehgeschädigte oder wie es – ja, also so heißt es, glaube ich, offiziell – und da wird eben momentan versucht, ein sehr viel breiteres Angebot an Hörformaten generell herzustellen. Da ist der Millanton ein Teil davon, da sollen die vor dem Spiel, nach dem Spielgespräche Teil davon sein, da ist die reine Berichterstattung der Spiele, also die Schilderung der 90 Minuten soll da veröffentlicht werden nach den Spielen, aber eben auch noch viel darüber hinaus. Und gerade beim FC Kauly finden ja auch Sachen statt wie Lesungen von Zeitzeugen aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, also politische Dimensionen. Und auch das wird aufgezeichnet und da als Audioformat zur Verfügung gestellt. Und damit haben wir natürlich eine sehr, sehr gute Verknüpfung mit dem Verein. Und ja, also das fehlt mir bei vielen anderen noch so ein bisschen, wird da immer eher aus der Ferne über einen Verein gesprochen. Und bei uns ist es tatsächlich so, dass wir da sehr gut, ja, das alles irgendwie zusammenbringen. Also was Klaas ja eben auch schon angedeutet hat, wir haben den Wolf dabei, der die blinden Reportage macht, der selber Trainer unserer blinden Fußball-Bundesliga-Mannschaft ist. Wir haben Justus, der eben Fanbetreuer ist, also im Fanprojekt sitzt und kriegen halt auch vom Verein jedwede Unterstützung, die wir da irgendwie benötigen. Und das ist tatsächlich eine Sache, worüber wir uns keinesfalls beschweren können, wo es andere Formate, glaube ich, sehr viel schwerer haben.
Erzähl das mal dem Axel vom Podcast.
Zum Beispiel.
Ich glaube, der hat ja versucht, mit dem FC Kontakt noch zu nehmen und ich glaube, es kam nicht mal eine Antwort, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe. Also da ist das, das ist ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal irgendwie auch für den Verein. Sehr, sehr positives Alleinstellungsmerkmal.
Es gibt auch eine eigene Sektion auf der Homepage, die sich, wo euer Feed einläuft, oder?
Ja, genau. Also eigentlich liegen wir ja auf dem Übersteigerblock, aber zusätzlich ist es eben so, dass dieses afmradio.org, das ist eben, wie gesagt, eigentlich eine Abteilung des Vereins, aber zusätzlich soll es sich jetzt eben so ein bisschen als Radiomedium auch positionieren. Und da wird der Millantum dann quasi gespiegelt, genau. Und da soll es dann eigene Rubriken geben, eben auch für die vor dem Spiel, nach dem Spielgespräche, für diese Zeitzeugengeschichten, für ich begleite eine Person mal einen Tag lang und schneide daraus eine Sendung zusammen. Sehr ambitioniertes, sehr ehrgeiziges Projekt, was jetzt schon so anderthalb Jahre im Werden ist. Die Homepage ist jetzt zumindest schon mal fertig. Es muss jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr mit Leben gefüllt werden über den Millantum und die Vor- und Nachdem-Spielgespräche hinaus. Kann dann sich aber sicherlich als wirklich schönes Audioportal für den FC St. Pauli dann auch eignen und das strahlt dann natürlich auch auf den Verein zurück, weil es eben eine vereintseigener Abteilung ist.
In jedem Fall bemerkenswert. Sehr schön, wie sich der Verein da zusammen schließt mit Fans. Ähnlich gute Zusammenarbeit im Blogbereich hat der erste FC Nürnberg und dazu gibt es auch einen Podcast Clubfans United. So wie der Blog heißt, so nennt sich auch der Podcast, bezieht sich auf den ersten FC Nürnberg. Soweit ich weiß, wird aber im Podcastbereich unterstützt der Club die Betreiber nicht. Das macht der Alexander-Endel-ATC-Publikum und der Stefan Hellmer. Kann man auch sehr gerne reinhören, vor allem auch, wenn man so ein bisschen fränkische, schwere Zunge mal hören möchte und einem das bisschen, was bei mir manchmal durchscheint, nicht reicht. Womit wir bei idiomisch geprägten Podcasts werden. Und da müssen wir über die beiden Podcast-Formate reden, die es zum 1. FC Kaiserslautern gibt.
Ja, soll ich mal anfangen. Es gibt den wunderschönen Namen Betze mehr Buckens. Ich habe das bestimmt ganz furchtbar schlecht ausgesprochen. Das Buckens mit P geschrieben. Und ich sage jetzt auch nochmal, der 1. FC Kaiserslautern ist nicht mein Verein, wahrlich nicht. Also ich würde den in der Sympathieskala tatsächlich ganz weit unten hin packen. Und beim FC St. Pauli ist die Region als Wort für diesen Verein tatsächlich felsenfest verankert. Also es sagt keiner mehr Kaiserslautern, es sagen alle nur die Region, weil es ja so furchtbar ist für die Region, wenn dann der Verein absteigt und alles stirbt. Betze mehr Buckens ist mir als Format aber aufgefallen über die vor dem Spiel, nach dem Spielgespräche, die wir machen. Und da haben wir wirklich inzwischen glaube ich vier Gespräche mit den Jungs vor und nach den zwei letzten Spielen jeweils geführt. Das sind – ich hoffe, ich tue keinem Unrecht – vier Jungs, die das machen, die drei davon auch nicht mehr in Kaiserslautern oder direkt drumrum wohnen, sondern sich inzwischen in Deutschland weit verteilt haben. Dementsprechend auch größtenteils ein Skype-Format, die sich noch nicht so ganz furchtbar regelmäßig zusammentreffen. Das ist in letzter Zeit ein bisschen regelmäßiger geworden. Und das Ganze setzt auf auf dem fck-blog.de. Die sind auch tatsächlich sehr, sehr gut mit dem Verein vernetzt. Also der Florian Dick war schon mal da zu einer Sendung. Und jüngst auch der Stefan Roskopf, der ja auf Twitter auch ein bisschen aktiv ist, der da – ich weiß gar nicht, was die offizielle Funktion ist. Ich glaube auch so was wie Pressesprecher beim fck ist. Und das sind auch sehr, sehr hörenswerte Sendungen dann immer. Ansonsten ist es natürlich rund um das Spiel, wo die vier sich dann halt besprechen, wie es jetzt gerade war oder wie das nächste Spiel dann sein wird. Aber gerade die Sendung mit den Gästen stechen da auch sehr positiv hervor.
Und man mag es kaum glauben, aber der fck hat auch noch einen zweiten Podcast am Start, der ebenfalls empfehlenswert ist, das Betze-Gebabel. Während Betze-Mehr-Backens auf dem FCK-Block aufsetzt, gehört Betze-Gebabel zu der Betze-Brennt, dem, glaube ich, größten Forum zum ersten FC Kaiserslautern. Und alleine aus dialektaler Sicht unbedingt empfehlenswert. Der erste FC Kaiserslautern ist auch nicht mein Verein, aber ich höre diesen Pfälzern eigentlich sehr gerne zu. Sie haben auch immer wieder nette Aktionen. Also zum einen gibt es die Betze-Wutz, in die immer eingezahlt wird bei schlechten Wortspielen. Das wäre mein persönlicher finanzieller Ruin. Und gleichzeitig aber eine sehr interessante Einbindung der Hörer via WhatsApp-Sprachnachricht. Durchaus ein System, das vielleicht auch für andere Formate interessant sein kann. Die Hörer schicken WhatsApp-Sprachnachrichten, die dann in die Sendung eingebunden werden. Insgesamt sehr höhenswert, wenn man mit dem Thema leben kann. Aber zum Beispiel jetzt die letzte Folge, ich glaube Folge 22 war das zum Abschluss der Saison. Und ein Rückblick war doch sehr höhenswert und gibt einem eigentlich dann auch sehr kompakt dann doch einen ganz guten Einblick, wie die lautern Fans das alles gerade so sehen, wie es bei ihnen läuft. Empfehlenswert.
Schon verrückt, wenn man sich das mit allen anderen Vereinen mal vergleicht.
Ja, da sieht man mal, wie es halt ist. Einer fängt an und befruchtet damit den anderen. Ein bisschen, na egal. Aber ich glaube, das war es auch schon an Zweitliga-Podcasts, oder habe ich was vergessen? Ich glaube nicht.
Es gab eine Zeit lang bei unser allerlieblings Verein RB Leipzig Champagner statt Bier. Das ist aber leider, soweit ich das sehe, nicht mehr aktuell. Und das bedauere ich sehr, weil die veröffentlichen immer noch mal so Tonsegmente. Aber ich glaube, wirkliche Folgen machen sie momentan nicht mehr, wenn ich das nicht völlig verpasst habe.
Stimmt, genau.
Vom Rote Brause-Blocker und wie gesagt, Champagner statt Bier, durchaus selbst ironisch gewählt. Und habe ich nicht so regelmäßig auf dem Schirm und wie gesagt, in letzter Zeit weniger verfolgt, aber kann man dann für den zukünftigen Erstligisten sicherlich mal auf die Liste packen.
Und hoffentlich haben wir bis zur nächsten Saison auch einen SV Darmstadt-Podcast. Das würde mich sehr freuen. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube, der FSV Frankfurt Podcast ist ganz kurz vor der Mach. Ich hoffe es doch. Damit haben wir die vereinsbezogenen Podcasts durchgesprochen.
Fand es ganz schön, dass du Darmstadt jetzt praktisch bei den Zweitligisten angekündigt hattest.
Das tut mir leid. Ich habe mit der Podroll ja angefangen, bevor die Aufstiegsplätze ausgespielt waren. Deswegen ist die Sortierung auch noch ein bisschen antik. Das muss ich noch umhauen, bis das dann online geht. Solange wird sich auch diese Veröffentlichung dieses Podcasts hinausziehen. Was für euch eine unnötige Information ist, denn in diesem Moment hören wir es ja schon. Speaking of unnötige Informationen, nein. Wir haben noch zwei Podcasts, die wir noch kurz erwähnen wollten, die nicht so ganz einfach zuzuordnen waren. Zum einen Spielverlagerungen. Die machen zusätzlich zu ihrer Seite auch einen Podcast. Wer sich für Taktik interessiert und vor diesen 40.000 Zeichenartikeln zurückschreckt wie ich, der wird sich darüber freuen und veröffentlichen sehr unregelmäßig, aber lohnt sich zu abonnieren und dann lohnt es sich auch rein zu hören. Man bekommt einen recht konzisen Überblick und dauert jetzt auch nicht länger so was zu hören, als einen Artikel von denen zu lesen. Und dann haben wir noch ein professionelles Produkt.
Vielleicht noch ein kurzes Wort zum Spielverlagerungspodcast. Man muss schon sagen, man muss sich schon ein bisschen mit der Spielverlagerungssprecher auseinandersetzen. Also irgendwie horizontal ausweichende Stürmer.
Das ist ein fremdsprachiger Podcast, ja.
Komische Halbverteidiger, Asymmetrien im Zentralmittelfeld und Staffelungen mit unterschiedlicher Interpretation. Habe ich mir kurz rausgeschrieben, weil ich habe heute mal reingehört, noch vor der Sendung und habe gedacht so, wow, also brauchst du immer so ein kleines Lexikon noch in der Hand, damit du alles mitkriegst.
Davon ist es mir manchmal ehrlich gesagt auch zu viel. Also Begriffe wie Deckungsschatten und so lassen sich noch recht leicht erklären und haben auch ihre Berechtigung. Aber teilweise gibt es auch Wortkreationen, wo ich mir denke, man hätte es auch anders ausdrücken können, ohne ein neues Wort zu erfinden und das ist eigentlich die größere Kunst, als sich ein Wort auszudenken. Das stimmt, das kann man als Kritikpunkt sagen. Aber es ist ja auch ganz nett, wenn man sich mal geistig herausfordern möchte. Man bleibt definitiv am Ball, denn ansonsten ist man nach dem Halbsatz schon wieder komplett draußen bei dem Podcast. Absolut.
Wortkreation ist aber natürlich auch eine schöne Überleitung, weil der zweite Podcast in der Reihe wäre dann, das was du eben schon sagtest, öffentlich-rechtlich, Zeiglers wunderbare Welt des Fußballs, dem sicherlich vielen vom WDR als Fernsehformat bekannt. Der hat in grauer Vorzeit bei Rheinübremen wöchentlich, jeweils am Freitagvormittag wurde das veröffentlicht, immer so zwei, drei Minuten zum Spieltag besprochen. Und das ist wirklich eine, ja, sehr höhrenswerte, ja, so eine Mischung aus TV total, Sepping und seiner Fernsehsendung, aber wirklich im positiven Sinne. Also das tut mir ein bisschen leid, dass ich TV total da erstmal reingebracht habe. Aber er schneidet halt Hörschnipsel zusammen aus Interviews, die irgendwie dann sich mit Fußball beschäftigen, auf eine sehr amüsante Art und Weise und verwurstet das zu so einem drei, vier Minuten an jedem Freitag und gehört aus meiner Sicht für jemanden, der sich mit Fußball beschäftigt, auf jeden Fall auf die Liste, weil es ist einfach immer ein kurzer Lacher zu jedem Spieltag vorweg und kostet eben im Gegensatz zu den meisten anderen Formaten nicht so furchtbar viel Zeit. Kann von daher auch gerne mal zwischendurch und meistens sogar tatsächlich dann auch zeitlich unabhängig gehört werden, aufgrund der Länge aber gar nicht zwingend nötig.
Ich finde auch, dass man danach Fußballübertragungen ganz anders zuhört. Also ich hatte das eine Zeit lang, da habe ich jede Folge davon gehört und auch öfter mal mir alte Folgen nochmal nacheinander angehört. Und man hört dann tatsächlich Versprecher oder unglückliche Formulierungen von Fußballkommentatoren viel, viel deutlicher. Es schult das Ohr.
Und Arndt hat eine sehr humorige Art zu sprechen. Also wir hatten das vorhin bei Marvin, wo man einfach sagt, er kann vorlesen, was er will. Man spürt, er hat Spaß dabei, was er da gerade erzählt. Und bei Arndt ist das nicht, dass er lustig das selber lachend irgendwie von sich gibt. Aber er hat so den Schalk im Nacken. Und da höre ich ihm einfach ungeheimlich gerne zu.
Wir sind am Ende unserer sehr langen Liste angelangt. Vielleicht noch ein kurzes Wort. Was ich persönlich gerne noch genannt hätte, wäre der Flutterball gewesen. Ein Format, was aber leider im April, glaube ich, eingestellt wurde, nach 150 irgendwas folgen. Schade. Vielleicht kommt er aber wieder. Ihr könnt ja, Stichwort, Hashtag sozialer Druck. Nervt ihn mal ein bisschen. Vielleicht fangen sie wieder an. Und ansonsten noch mal der Hinweis. Obwohl wir jetzt gefühlte drei Stunden Podcast-Empfehlungen ausgesprochen haben, haben wir trotzdem nicht alle genannt, die es da so zu finden gibt. Deshalb geht auf rasenfunk.de slash Podroll. Da versuche ich, eine vollständige Liste zu erstellen, die sehr gerne ergänzt werden kann. Im besten Falle wäre es irgendwann so, wie es mal bei der Blogshow war, die ich mal gemacht hatte, dass neue Blogs sich automatisch bei mir gemeldet haben und dann alle davon profitiert haben. Ich konnte die dann gleich über Twitter verbreiten und die hatten paar Leser und ich hatte gleich wieder eine aktualisierte Blogliste in dem Fall und sehr schön wäre das, wenn man mit Podcasts das auch hinbekäme. Ich finde es übrigens auch schön, wenn das noch andere Podcasts auf ihren Seiten machen würden, ähnlich wie man mal die Blogroll hatte, dass man andere Podcasts empfiehlt. Warum denn eigentlich nicht?
Und vor allen Dingen können die Podcasts auch gerne was miteinander machen. Also da einfach über den Schatten springen. Ich habe bei einigen noch das Gefühl, dass sie das Gefühl haben, dass wenn sie irgendwen anders empfehlen, dass ihnen dann die Hörer flöten gehen. Und ich glaube, das ist im Podcast-Bereich genau andersrum. Also man muss die Leute dann nur noch immer süchtiger machen und die hören umso mehr und umso mehr und umso mehr.
Ich glaube auch, man wächst miteinander. Ich glaube, man stiet sich kein einzigen Hörer. Damit haben wir euch ganz viele Podcast-Empfehlungen gegeben. Wenn euch jetzt noch langweilig ist, dann habt ihr wirklich zu viel Zeit. Ich denke, so kann man es sagen. Tja, was bleibt jetzt noch zu sagen? Jetzt haben wir hier zwei Podcast-Macher sitzen, im Grunde ja drei. Deswegen könnte ich eigentlich die Frage an Klaas stellen. Was würdest du dir denn noch von deinen Hörern wünschen in Zukunft?
Also ich bin erstmal natürlich sehr zufrieden mit unseren Hörern, weil die sich in den Kommentaren zum Beispiel – Schleime. Ja, so ein bisschen, ja, ist es schon so. Nein, also da können wir uns wirklich was so das Feedback angeht, was Spielszenen zum Beispiel angeht, das ist ganz toll. Aber ich glaube, so allgemein haben manchmal die Leute, die denken dann, ach, das hört ja eh jeder, das brauche ich gar nicht mehr empfehlen oder so. Ich glaube, das ist gerade in diesem Fußballbereich auch so, wir haben ja vorhin über die Zahlen auch gesprochen. Also wenn man Podcastern was Gutes tun will, dann empfiehlt man das vielleicht einfach dem Mann, der im Stadion neben einem sitzt oder dem Onkel, der Tante oder den Facebook-Freunden oder so. Das wäre für uns, glaube ich, richtig schön, diese Empfehlungskultur einfach auch zu nutzen über die verschiedenen Netzwerke, auf denen man sich so bewegt. Zum Beispiel oder halt ganz normal im Gespräch und dann dem Nachbar und dem nebenan einfach mal auf dem Smartphone einen Podcatcher einzubauen.
Ja, sehr wichtiger Punkt, der finde ich auch. Auch durchaus eben Leuten, die gar nicht so podcastaffin sind, merkt man ja auch an unser aller Downloadzahlen und ja auch beim Rasenfunk, da ist noch einiges möglich. Bei uns sind da auch sehr wichtig iTunes-Rezensionen. Also zumindest merkt man dann immer so einen kleinen Schub. Ist das bei euch denn auch so?
Ich habe mir da ehrlich gesagt nie Gedanken darüber gemacht, bis ich es bei euch mal gehört habe, dass euch das wohl was bringt. Ich kann es noch nicht nachvollziehen. Erklär doch vielleicht mal den Zusammenhang.
Es geht letztlich um die Auffindbarkeit in iTunes und die ist für den Rasenfunk schlecht, obwohl wir eigentlich schon die richtigen Keywords verwenden. Es hat ein bisschen mit dem Namen zu tun, dadurch, dass wir das Bundesliga nicht im Titel haben. Aber da habe ich jetzt auch – also ich glaube, das ist ein Rasenfunk – die Bundesliga-Schlusskonferenz, glaube ich. Das muss ja wohl reichen. Vielleicht auch nur die Schlusskonferenz. Das muss aber auch reichen. Das ist einfach ein schöner Name. Also da habe ich jetzt keinen Bock, wegen iTunes rumzumachen. Aber tatsächlich ist es so, dass wir so – wenn mal wieder so ein neuer Schwunghörer rüberkommt, dann hat das meistens damit zu tun, dass wir bei iTunes mal gut gerankt waren, wieder in den Top-Podcasts der einzelnen Kategorie. Also nicht generell, da hat man eh keine Chance. Aber in der Sportkategorie war zumindest immer mein subjektiver Eindruck. Deswegen rufe ich ja auch in jeder Folge dazu auf, obwohl es ja immer so ein bisschen so Battlen vor Likes finde ich immer so ein bisschen doof eigentlich. Ich will auch nicht mehr hören, wie wahnsinnig toll die Leute das finden, aber also uns hat das gefühlt immer was gebracht.
Dann rufen wir jetzt hiermit alle noch mal dazu auf, für den Rasenfunk bei iTunes mal eine schöne Rezension zu schreiben.
Ja und vor allem auch Collinas Erben und Millenton, ganz wichtig. Also bei uns bringt es wirklich was, vor allem weil wir auch ein Großteil unserer Abonnenten zumindest laut Feedpress über Apple, über eben iTunes bekommen. Also da ist Android noch in der klaren Minderheit, wobei ich bei den Zahlen so ein bisschen schwierig, weil das müsste natürlich getrackt sein, um das wirklich hinzukriegen. Na jetzt wird es ein bisschen technisch. Aber zumindest ist der Eindruck, dass Podcasts immer noch eher auf Apple Geräten verbreitet sind und da ist dann natürlich iTunes wichtig.
Wenn ich mir was von unseren Hörern wünschen dürfte, dann wären das natürlich auch iTunes-Rezensionen ganz wichtig, aber noch viel mehr. Ja, klingt jetzt komisch. Ehrliches Feedback. Also ich habe immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl, es kommt sehr schnell so ein, ach Mensch, klasse, wieder super gehört und total unterhaltsam und zwölf Stunden Spaß ohne Ende, Party in Dosen. Ja, ist richtig, glaube ich, auch tatsächlich bei uns. Aber schöner wäre natürlich, wenn jemand auch mal sagt, ja, okay, das war zu viel Gesappel. Haltet doch mal die Fresse, trinkt drei Bier weniger. Das kann man ja höflich formulieren oder auch konstruktiv. Das tut sich natürlich auf Twitter immer ein bisschen schwerer zu formulieren, weil 140 Zeichen dafür vielleicht nicht ausreichen, aber dafür ist der Artikel ja dann auch im Blog ansteuerbar. Und da würde ich mich sehr darüber freuen, wenn da zu den einzelnen Episoden ein paar mehr Worte verloren werden. Da kann man ja das immer noch sehr höflich machen und auch sagen, insgesamt hat es mir gut gefallen, aber der ein oder andere Punkt, den hätte ich mir ausführlicher oder weniger ausführlicher gewünscht. Normalerweise habe ich in Deutschland – und das ist jetzt vielleicht auch so ein Berufsding – immer das Gefühl, nicht gemeckert ist genug gelobt. Also wenn Kritik kommt, dann ist sie in erster Linie erst mal negativ und wenn nicht gemeckert wird, dann ist das alles schon irgendwie okay gewesen. Und tatsächlich in diesem Internet-Blog-Podcast-Gedöns ist es so ein bisschen anders. Also es wird sehr schnell gelobt. Aber dass da wirklich mal jemand mit fundierter und konstruktiver Kritik kommt, das passiert leider sehr selten. Vielleicht aus so einer falschen Höflichkeit heraus, dass man denkt, wenn ich dem jetzt erzähle, das kannst du besser machen, dann ist das irgendwie unhöflich und der macht das ja in seiner Freizeit. Und ich will dem ja nicht wehtun. Aber deswegen nochmal, man kann das ja durchaus in der Sache formulieren und dann bin ich zumindest da auch sehr dankbar für.
Ja absolut. Kann ich mir auch nur anschließen. Und was ich auch sehr, sehr mag, sind Kommentare. Nicht nur Feedback, also da stehe ich auch sehr drauf, aber ich mag es auch sehr, wenn in den Artikeln, die zu der einzelnen Folge publiziert werden, in den Kommentaren dann weiter diskutiert wird. Also es wird eine Aussage rausgenommen und dann, also das sehe ich aus diesen und diesen Gründen anders. Das mag ich sehr, weil es ist ja nie so, dass man die absolute Wahrheit verkauft. Ich hoffe, ich verliere jetzt keine Hörer. Aber nein, wir sind nicht die Päpste des Fußballpodcasts. Wir sind nicht unfehlbar und es stimmt auch nicht alles. Und man kann halt auch immer alles anders sehen. Und ich mag das immer sehr, wenn ausgehend von einer Episode dann nochmal neue Diskussionen entstehen. Dem gucke ich sehr gut sehr gerne zu. Und in einer perfekten Welt könnte man das dann immer in die nächste Folge gleich mit reinziehen. Da fand ich übrigens die Mitarbeit der Hörer am Rasenfunk Royal wirklich herausragend. Das hätte ich nie gedacht, dass da so viele Fragen an die Gäste kommen.
Du hast ja aber so ein Google-Dokument gemacht, was für jeden offen war, ne?
Genau. Und man konnte halt zu jedem der 18 Gäste, zu jedem Verein Fragen stellen. Ich habe das aus so einem Gefühl heraus gemacht, dass ich mir dachte, damit kann man dem Vorwurf begegnen, man hätte nicht die richtigen Fragen gestellt. Aber es kamen wirklich auch zu jedem Fall wirklich interessante Punkte zusammen. Vielleicht sollte man sowas auch öfter machen, habe ich schon drüber nachgedacht. Jetzt für meine Formate, aber vielleicht für euch ja auch interessant, vorher noch mal Feedback einholen, wenn man die Gästeliste hat.
Ich habe natürlich dann immer so ein bisschen Angst. Wer weiß, was dann kommt. Aber gut, da muss man dann mal probieren. Ich habe das Google Doc bei dir ja auch gesehen, vorher schon, und habe gedacht, meine Fresse, was für wirklich unfassbar viele, aber dann tatsächlich auch gute Fragen. Das hat mich sehr beeindruckt.
Absolut, ja. Ich meine, man muss dann die Eier haben, dann doch hin und wieder ist eine dabei, die ist nicht so stark. Oder manchmal ging es auch in die Richtung, wo ich mir gedacht habe, nee, das sollte eigentlich in dieser Sendung nicht so sein. Also spekulieren um Transfers war jetzt bei mir so das Thema. Da habe ich einfach keinen Bock drauf. Das ist nicht die Art von Journalismus, in Anführungszeichen, die ich machen will. Aber kann man ja sagen und dann weglassen. Nee, vielleicht sollten das wirklich mehr Podcasts machen. Würde ich persönlich auch gerne mitmachen. Gerade auch bei so Punkten wie Spielen meines Lebens zum Beispiel auf meinen Sportradio wäre doch total interessant, vorher dem Trainer noch mal zu fragen, Cameron, really? Naja, ja, das wünschen wir uns von unseren Hörern. Und damit dürften wir wirklich so ziemlich alles besprochen haben. Vielleicht machen wir jetzt noch einen kleinen Bogen und reden nicht nur über Sportpodcasts, sondern ganz kurz noch. Klaas, welche Podcasts, die über den Sportbereich hinausgehen, hörst du denn gern und kannst du noch empfehlen?
Ist natürlich auch vollkommen unvorständlich, aber ich würde erst mal das komplette Övere von Deutschlandfunk und WDR 5 empfehlen, dass man da einfach mal sich so ein bisschen ranwagt und auch in die verschiedensten Kategorien geht. Auslandsberichterstattung, Kultur, alles Mögliche. Einfach mal ausprobieren und dann natürlich mein Lieblingspodcast aktuell, Samft und sorgfältig von Oli Schulz und Jan Böhmermann.
Oh ja.
Wunderbare Sendung. Die beiden spielen sich die Bälle zu, haben irre Ideen. Dann, wir haben es vorhin schon mal gesagt, CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Da gibt es glaube ich mittlerweile 200 Folgen oder so. Die meisten sind sehr, sehr zeitlos. Also da könnt ihr auch – es gibt überhaupt keinen Grund mehr für Langeweile in Zukunft. Ihr merkt das. Dann auch die alten Folgen der Mikrodilettanten. Ich glaube, die haben aufgehört. Jetzt, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, was sehr, sehr schade ist, einer von denen, der Nicolas Sehmack, einfach mal auch bei Eilschuens eingeben, der macht noch andere Podcasts, wo er auch zum Beispiel über Ebola, Mobbing und Polizeigewalt redet. Sehr, sehr guter Mann, Nicolas Sehmack. Ich wiederhole es noch mal. Und dann sowas wie das Küchenradio oder der Schöne Ecken Podcasts. Das sind Podcasts, die auch mal rausgehen, sich irgendwo Sachen angucken und dann kriegt man halt mit, wie die Leute irgendwo langlaufen und dann darüber erzählen. Auch sehr empfehlenswert. Und noch ein schöner Podcast zum Schluss ist, was wichtig ist. Da redet Sebastian Fiebrich vom Textilvergehen mit seinem Sohn. Finde ich auch sehr schön.
Absolut. Auch einer meiner Lieblingspodcasts. Ich steige da mal ein und gehe mal meinen Podcatcher gerade alphabetisch durch. Der Radio-Tatort der ARD kann ich empfehlen. Gibt es, glaube ich, einmal im Monat. Wer auf Hörspiele steht, immer ganz angenehm. Upvoted bei Reddit. Wenn man sich für Reddit interessiert oder generell für Themen, die im Internet wichtig sind, dann lohnt sich dieser Podcast. CAE hast du schon genannt. Das ARD-Radio-Feature auch immer wieder sehr interessant. Stimmt. Fehlfarben – ein Kulturpodcast aus München. Den höre ich natürlich aus personeller Verbundenheit zu allen Machern und auch, weil ich es schön finde, dass sie Bezug nehmen auf den Fehlpass-Podcast. Auch sehr zu empfehlen. Geekweek ist so ein Technikpodcast, den ich eigentlich jede Folge höre. Außerdem Geekwerkstatt unbedingt zu empfehlen. Und das sage ich nur, weil Frank mich sonst haut. Das ist nämlich sein Podcast, den er noch betreibt. Hört da unbedingt rein und lest auch das Blog. Ich hoffe, die Überweisung kommt pünktlich. Wer sich für Wissenschaft interessiert, methodisch inkorrekt. Sehr interessant, sehr umfangreich. Also dauert, glaube ich, keine Folge unter drei Stunden. Aber wenn man sich für die Wissenschaftswelt interessiert und für alle Blüten, die die so umfasst, unbedingt empfehlenswert.
Ich würde sogar darüber hinausgehen, dass es auch für Leute, die nichts mit Wissenschaft am Hut haben, ein guter Einblick auch mal in die Wissenschaftswelt.
Ja, das kann man eigentlich so sagen. Jetzt habe ich hier nebenan Raumzeit angemacht. Das war der letzte Podcast, den ich gehört habe. Raumzeit zu viele. Raumzeit 58. Außerdem alles interessant, was Gimlet Media produziert. Das ist ein Start-up aus den USA von Alex Blumberg, heißt er. Der hat bei This American Life, das ist eine sehr bekannte Radiosendung und auch Podcast, in den USA gearbeitet und hat inzwischen drei Podcasts. Der erste Podcast, Start-up, unbedingt empfehlenswert, handelt davon, wie er seinen Podcast Start-up gründet. Ist deshalb so empfehlenswert, weil er qua Definition immer das Tonband hat mitlaufen lassen. Das heißt, wir hören nicht nur, wie er bei Investoren gepitcht hat und zwar nicht nur bei kleinen Investoren, sondern zum Beispiel auch bei Chris Sacker, einem der größten Investoren oder Venture-Capitalist, in den USA. Sondern man hört dann auch, wie er mit seiner Frau mögliche Namen der neuen Firma bespricht. Oder man hört, wie er mit dem neuen Teilhaber bespricht, wer wie viele Prozente an der Firma haben soll. Sehr, sehr guter Podcast, sehr interessant. Gibt es inzwischen schon in einer zweiten Staffel. Da begleiten sie Dating RIN. Das ist eine Dating-App. Auch ganz interessant. Die erste Staffel fand ich persönlich noch besser. Und alle Shows, die er mit diesem neuen gegründeten Unternehmen macht, sind eigentlich höhendswert. Es gibt die Mystery Show und noch Reply All. Das ist eine Internetshow. Sehr, sehr gut gemachtes Radio, sage ich jetzt mal. Und das Storytelling, das die Amerikaner im Podcast drauf haben, ist einfach Bombe. Muss man einfach so sagen. Sehr schade, dass es so ein Not Safe for Work nicht mehr gibt. Aber wer es noch nicht kannte, kann mal in alte Folgen reinholen. Es lohnt sich meiner Meinung nach. Radio Nukolar habe ich vorhin schon genannt. Popkulturell ist quasi für Leute, die so alt sind wie, keine Ahnung, wir. Also ich bin jetzt 30. Ich bin, glaube ich, so genau ziemlich die Zielgruppe. Nur das Problem ist, ich hatte zu spät Privatfernsehen, deswegen kann ich trotzdem nicht immer mitreden. Der wichtigste und größte Podcast aus den USA, Serial, hat so ein bisschen die große Podcastwelle in den USA gegründet. Mit Serial kam Podcast im Mainstream in den USA an. Und mit Mainstream meine ich, dass die Macherin von Serial bei Letterman eingeladen war und einen großen Talkshows und die letzte Folge, glaube ich, 50 Millionen Downloads hatte. Serial begleitet einen Kriminalfall über, ich glaube, 12 Folgen hinweg und einen echten Kriminalfall und bewegt sich immer zwischen der Frage, ist der Verurteilte zurechtverurteilt worden oder nicht. Ich will nicht spoilern, aber lohnt sich unbedingt das unheimlich gut gemachte Podcasting und werden auch, glaube ich, zwei neue Staffeln bringen. Ich glaube, Ende dieses Jahres und wahrscheinlich dann im nächsten Jahr. Sehr empfehlenswert. Wer sich im Bereich Social Media aufhält, socialgenius.de. Ich mag auch sehr die Sternengeschichten. Geht dann eher um Astrophysik und alles, was mit dem Weltraum zu tun haben. Stuff you should know and you missed in history class ist das, mit dem man sein Allgemeinwissen aufbessern kann und hilft einem auch ein bisschen, sein Englisch aufzubessern.
Hast du mich gerade angesprochen oder?
Wir sitzen nicht in einem Raum. Du weißt gar nicht, in welche Richtung ich geguckt habe.
Da war mein Name mit im Podcast, hatte ich gedacht. Und dann klang das so, als ob ich jetzt mein Allgemeinwissen aufbessern müsste.
Ach, jetzt habe ich es erst verstanden. Badamtss. Entschuldigung, für mich ist es schon zu spät. Mögt ihr das auch so, wenn im Podcast Zeitangaben verwendet werden und man selbst sitzt dann gerade in der U-Bahn und denkt sich ja, betrifft mich nicht?
Ich mag es immer ganz gerne, dann weiß ich das besser einzuschätzen. 23.59 Uhr.
Ja, 23.59 Uhr an einem Sonntagabend. Und ich habe schon wieder Raumzoll angemacht. Man sieht, dass ich wirklich ein bisschen müde bin. Also ich höre sehr viele Podcasts. Man merkt, dass ich versuche, das jetzt mal zu einem Ende zu bringen. Ihr wisst gar nicht, wie viele ich weggelassen habe. Die adapters, sehr guter Podcast über Endzeit-Theorien beschäftigt sich wissenschaftlich mit der Frage, was kommt nach dem Menschen auf der Erde? Sehr, sehr gut. Ich empfehle die Folge zu den Ratten. The Biggest Story in the World über Alan Rusbridger, den inzwischen ehemaligen Guardian-Chef, der sich als letzte große Aufgabe auf die Fahnen geschrieben hat, den Klimawandel zu bekämpfen. The Great Albums – da reden Musikjournalisten und Musikpodcaster jeweils über ein großes Album. Wer hätte es erwartet? Kann man sich sehr gut rauspicken, was einen persönlich interessiert. Alle Podcasts von The Verge, This American Life – definitiv auch empfehlenswert. Und ich würde sagen, damit muss ich jetzt dann eigentlich Schluss machen. Ich hätte noch ein paar zu nennen, aber das muss eigentlich auch reichen. Es gibt so viele tolle Podcasts.
Du musst sehr, sehr viele Show-Notes machen, das ist dir schon klar, ne?
Ach Gott, die muss ich da auch alle reinschreiben. Stimmt, du hast recht, ich habe ja nur den Rest in Rasenfunk.de. Das Gute ist, ihr werdet diese Folge jetzt also hören, nach dem zweiten Spieltag der Bundesligasaison 2016-2017.
Ich bin gespannt, ob Maik denn überhaupt Lust bekommen hat, auch mal was außerhalb von Fußball zu hören.
Ich habe jetzt irgendwie drei Namen mitgeschrieben, habe jetzt selber noch mal geguckt, was ich noch höre. Ich höre noch 6MinuteEnglish vom BBC Radio und das war es dann auch. Und den ARD-Radio Tardot hast du, glaube ich, schon genannt, also von daher muss ich mal gucken, wie ich das zeitlich alles noch unterbringen kann.
Ja, ich meine, man kann ja auch Podcasts sehr selektiv hören, das finde ich ist auch das Schöne. Wir haben vorhin über die Vorteile von Podcasts geredet. Podcast-Episoden laufen einem nicht davon. Das heißt, auch von den genannten Podcasts höre ich ja nicht jede Folge, jede Woche, da wirst du ja wahnsinnig. Aber ich weiß einfach, das sind gute Formate. Und wenn mir dann danach ist, dann gucke ich, was haben die so als letzte Folgen gemacht. Und das finde ich ist ein riesen Vorteil. Und dann höre ich halt einfach mal wieder sieben Stunden am Stück methodisch inkorrekt, weil ich gerade wieder Bock habe auf Wissenschaftsgelaber und auf witzige Physiker-Witze. Und dann nebenher noch ein bisschen was lernen in einem Bereich, in dem ich mich nicht so auskenne. Und am nächsten Tag höre ich mir halt an, wie der Guardian versucht, einen guten Podcast zu produzieren. Übrigens sehr interessant, wenn man das Storytelling vom Guardian mal neben This American Life hält, aber das jetzt dann schon sehr theoretisch.
Es gibt ja auch Leute, die hören Podcasts in doppelter Geschwindigkeit. Könnte ich nicht.
Ich höre es manchmal beim Schneiden der Folgen.
Ja gut, klar. Aber selbst einen ganzen Podcast, den du nicht kennst, in doppelter Geschwindigkeit, am besten noch in einer anderen Sprache, ich wäre aufgeschlossen.
Ja, das stimmt. In einer anderen Sprache ist es schwierig. Andererseits ist es, also mir geht es dann manchmal so, wenn ich meinen eigenen Podcast in doppelter Geschwindigkeit nochmal angehört habe, bin ich sehr enttäuscht von meiner eigenen Stimme. Das ist so ein bisschen wie, wenn man Masi Moto hört und dann Materia. Wobei da ist es, naja, gut, da hört sich beides gut an, aber so vom Prinzip her. Nun denn, wir haben selten so viel mit Links um uns geschmissen in einer Sendung. Ich würde gerne mal die Notizzettel sehen, die die Podcasthörer jetzt in Händen halten, weil sie natürlich alles eifrig mitgeschrieben haben. Nochmal der Hinweis, es wird Shownotes geben. Danke Klaas auch nochmal, dass du mich dran erinnerst.
Ich möchte von dieser diese Zettel mit den Notizen, möchte ich abfotografiert sehen. Entweder in den Kommentaren oder mit dem Hashtag.
Eine Information, die jetzt für niemanden relevant ist, außer uns. Ja gut, also Podrollzettel ist der offizielle Hashtag zur Sendung. Ne, gebt uns gerne Feedback, ihr lieben Hörer. Ergänzt gerne unsere Liste, sowohl was die im Fußballpodcast angeht, vielleicht kann man das auch auf Sportpodcasts ausweiten, ich weiß es nicht, ob ich dieses fasse. Jetzt habe ich es gerade schon aufgemacht. Oh man, es ist wirklich spät. Ihr beiden, ich danke euch sehr, sehr, dass ihr mitgemacht habt. Vielen Dank, Maik Krükemeier, es ist mir unfassbar peinlich, dass ich den falschen Nachnamen gesagt habe. Da ging es schon mal gut los. Tut mir sehr leid, aber vielen Dank, dass du trotzdem dabei geblieben bist.
Sehr gerne und der andere Maik, der war ja früher auch beim Übersteiger, das passt schon. Es hat mir auch sehr viel Spaß gemacht, war klasse.
Freut mich. Ehrlich gesagt habe ich euch auch ganz lange miteinander verwechselt. Und vielen lieben Dank, Klaas, dass du mit rhetorisch etwas weniger begabten Menschen dich abgibst in deiner Freizeit und hier mit dabei warst.
Das ist eine Frechheit, euch beiden selbst gegenüber.
Ich meinte damit nur mich, sonst hätte ich ja Maik beleidigt.
Ja gut, Maik habe ich ja vorhin schon beleidigt. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das vorhin rausgekommen ist, dass er den Millantor moderiert.
Ich weiß es nicht. Kannst du uns noch mal kurz sagen, was dein Verein ist, vielleicht abschließend?
Ja, die Roten Riesen aus Hannover.
Ach so, ich dachte, im Prinzip könnten es die Leute auch nach dem Ausschlussverfahren machen, weil du so oft gesagt hast, was nicht dein Verein ist. Und dann kommt man noch bei Hannover 96 und Betis Sevilla raus.
Ja, nachher denkt noch einer Wolfsburg, von daher sage ich es lieber noch mal.
Ja, stimmt, von denen gibt es auch keinen Podcast. Ja, wir lassen das so im Raum stehen.
Genau. Hat mir auch viel Spaß gemacht, gute Idee. Und ich hoffe darauf, dass die Leute noch mehr Podcasts hören und noch mehr Feedback geben. Wir haben es ja alles gesagt.
Ja, absolut. Aber jetzt wiederholen wir uns und das muss in einem Podcast wirklich nicht sein, vor allem, wenn man nur knackige zwei Stunden irgendwas aufgenommen hat. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich und ihr lieben Hörer da draußen, bewertet uns bei iTunes. Nein, folgt uns bei Twitter und bei Facebook. Das reicht. Das muss reichen. Und dann, wie war es? Podroll, Zettel ist das Hashtag. Wir freuen uns. Vielen lieben Dank und bis zum nächsten Tribünengespräch, wahrscheinlich dann im Jahr 2017, wenn das mit meinem Zeitbudget weiter so aussieht wie bisher. Aber wir bemühen uns. Macht's gut.